Bo
is
for the you know the late start here uh
for the education committee I want to
welcome everybody to education today we
have 20 bills which we've retained uh we
initially had 109 20 of them were
retained
uh so and we've had a number of
subcommittee meetings and committee the
whole meetings on these bills throughout
the fall here and so today is the day
where we have to make some some critical
decisions here and all those bills um
just is a little bit of levity before we
started into it I was coming down and
getting my usual cup of coffee at uh in
holderness at Dunkin Donuts I walked in
and said the usual thing I I know the
people well and they I said I'll have a
small coffee with four milks in it
and she came back and said anything else
I said yeah with a senior discount she
Saidi want to see
ID and it just took me back I mean I was
just FL and I said yeah good morning and
so good morning you all too um what
we're going to do here today because we
do have several things on the docket
um um we do have we absolutely will be
taking a break at 12:30 today we have
another subcommittee is dealing with
administrative rules uh with uh uh uh
changes which are coming up uh to Jael
carard this this later this week so
we're going to have to take care of that
for a half hour from 12:30 to 1:00 that
group we will meet and those
subcommittee people are on this
committee right here so in the meantime
we're going to go ahead and
start um we have had one question
already this morning and we're working
with the speaker's office on that and so
we will be taking a break here in a
second or two to try to get some
resolution on that um so what I'm going
to do I know you're not going to like
this very much but we're going to take a
brief caucus for 10 minutes until we can
get some understanding from the
speaker's office where we are in that so
we're going to take a total caucus here
I'm going to meet with representative
cordelli representative Milo and
represent luno and try to start
organizing today's docket here so 10
minutes we'll be right back in here
thank you office yeah we we'll meet in
the office
break
okay
well
in the session here and we what we want
to do is I'm going to hand out we have a
lot of amendments to bills up here and
to committee members I know everybody
does not have all these amendments so I
would ask that when we put out notice
when we ask people to come forward with
their amendments I'm going to pass out
some right now uh to make sure that you
have these copies on
266 uh I'm going just pass these around
and everybody should have a copy this is
266 this is the rewriting of 193 e c h k
Etc uh we went through a long study on
that remember the bill pardon me I'm
need to get one of those back need one
back yeah I need
okay es Senate Bill
2390 now if you have a copy of the
amendment I know some people have copies
please don't take those copies let you
know somebody else you know en enjoy the
reading yeah another bill which we have
coming up is uh 637 there is an
amendment for that bill uh this bill
deals with um uh relative calculation of
average daily membership and attendance
and average daily membership and
residence for certain home educated
pupils we had discussion on this uh if
you have a copy please do not take a
copy I'll pass these
around let's see go that way
that this you which one you passing
right
there okay that
okay and this is
637 if you have a copy I think we passed
that
next one is
uh an amendment for HB
354 245h is the amendment I'll pass
those
out
[Music]
what
if we already have a copy I'll stick the
that
uh thank you I actually just ran in said
hello and came
set
okay where' everybody go here did anyone
[Music]
up
okay okay I'm going to go ahead and even
though we're not all here go ahead and
start I think our public has waited long
enough still have more amendments oh
well where are they no no we thought you
were calling no no no no if you have
amendments please let us know there's
amendments yes let's get Linda's
Amendment so this is amendment to house
school
and then we also have
Amendment from representative
test
okay is this uh his pile right here this
right here
was okay so that that Amendment goes
arene apparently he's gonna go to try to
around
more well we're trying to get these all
around right now that's fun for him
thank
go
439 um I having a new Amendment DED for
Amendment which is
this do we have do you have a copy this
don't that's the only one I have that
are there any more 577 amendments
floating around
here
see
577 uh 2278 H this is an amendment
dealing with it's yours representative
Damon deals with catastrophic Aid one
times per amendment
[Music]
577 5 577 is much like what you're doing
representative Heath with the study for
catastrophic or special education
a this is one right here which is just
doing it right in this
that okay we're going to go ahead and
and uh anything we're missing we'll get
it distributed we're wasting a lot of
time here critical time I'd like to
start off with uh 352 hb3
health
didn't have a name yeah I did it was it
yeah represent beler do you have a
352 thank you Mr chair yes I would like
to move uh in expedient to
legislate is there a second on 352 the
inexpedient to
legislate I'll second representative
luno seconds
that further discussion from the maker
of the
bill motion yes uh thank you Mr chair
and just to clarify this uh the reason I
think we're trying to move forward with
an it on this bill is is very simply
that um it's being considered
unnecessary there's nothing in current
law that prohibits a student from taking
a a day due to a genuine mental health
concern uh that's already allowed um
this just complicates matters further
and would seemingly uh create issues
with
um missing tests missing other things
and not being able to um hold that
against the student which or or require
them to make it up even which which
would be a really big
problem thank you represent luno do
you okay for those folks this bill just
gives an unexcused absence for those
that W calling in and saying I have a
mental health day I want to take um
basically this a local decision local
school districts do this in terms of a
child being sick and they require that
after three days or possibly five days a
doctor's certificate a company explain
or a doctor's note explaining that there
was an illness so with that um any
further
discussion Madam clerk would you please
Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
Ford yes representative beler yes
representative
dry
yes representative McDonald
no representative Noble yes
representative peternell yes
representative cell yes represent Miler
yeah representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative Luna yes representative
Heath yes representative Woodcock
no representative Hall yes
representative Bon yes representative
Daman doesn't work either
no
yes 17 y three
Nays
okay minority is there going to be a
Minority Report on
that not for me Mr chair put
this yeah that's the about the bottom
line where you can do something like is
that okay with everybody yeah okay we'll
put that on consent Jen we have several
mics that are not working up here could
know thank
you uh the next bill which we're going
625 HB 625 is relative to the
calculation of the average daily
membership in attendance and the average
represent
yeah it's Daisy Chain
okay okay
uh we uh from the maker of the motion do
you have any
discussion uh no I think there's another
uh companion bill that um uh addresses
the same topic that we will be
discussing shortly represent Miler no
any further discussion from the
committee
mam clerk would you please call the roll
on
625 Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative
leus yes representative Ford yes
representative beler yes representative
dry yes representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
Pell yes representative corello yes
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative luno yes representative
Heath yes representative wock yes
representative Hall yes representative
Bon yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad
yes 20a
Zer thank you we'll put that on
consent next bill we're going to address
quickly here is SB
25 this bill repeals a requirement for a
payments look for a motion
representative
cordelli I would move itl
second okay so we have a motion itl on
620 or on sb25 made by represent
cordelli second by uh represent M
represent cordelli do you have anything
to say in the bill I believe this is a
duplicate of legislation that was
already
passed represent Miley no y That's right
this is a duplication of a bill that's
law if if I might add to that I believe
we um retained this just waiting to see
what happened with the other Bill yes we
did represent C you
ready
yes
yes it's repealing a requirement for
report on Charter Public School
payments Vice chairman
cordelli yes representative leus yes
representative Ford yes representative
elure yes representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes
representative peternell yes
representative corello yes
representative Miler
yes representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
lunell yes representative Heath yes
representative wock yes representative
Hall yes representative Boni yes
representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad
Ma
now were there any mics on this side
that we not working I think we're okay
okay
okay we're going to jump to the top now
here
yeah should do mention if any's 437 it's
going to be a
while and
Public Safety Public Safety is going to
be here for this one okay uh is anybody
here waiting for 437 it will be a while
we don't have all the materials over
from
OS okay yeah I see some hands back there
what we're going to try to do is work
with Public Safety we want you guys back
out on the
road so so we're going to try to take
some of those bills up first here so
when we're dealing with um like criminal
background checks and performing
background checks and also schools may
use Transportation networks um let's
deal with the bill that's doing with uh
650 pardon
me you could do 155
also
155 yeah we we could we could do that
right now but let's try and get some of
our folks out of here yeah okay um HB
651 um that's School TOS may use
Transportation networks do we have an
do
here more oh this is all the same yeah
for
okay everybody should have a copy at
me I look to represent cordelli for a
motion
uh thank you Mr chairman I'd like to
move on to pass is there a
second represent LE uh ought to pass on
651 made by representative cordelli
second by representative leus uh
represent cordelli yes I would also like
to move um Amendment uh
there take a CH this all of us are
getting this pretty much for the first
it okay who's making a second on
that okay we need to have a second on
that okay represent
Pell okay representa cordelli can you
take us through this thing
please yes thank you
um this is a retained bill that relates
to uh new Transportation
vehicles
um we over the summer worked
extensively um with uh the um Department
of Transportation motor ve Motor
Vehicles Division um on this language um
and a uh a ride sharing company called
uh ever driven
um it's a it's a niche service really um
and it is a great
alternative um for foster care children
um you could have a foster care child
placed uh you know on a Monday and no uh
bus route assigned
for that child this gives school
districts great flexibility for foster
care kids special needs children um uh
homeless um I see it as a great
alternative also for we've had lots of
discussions um for uh children with IEPs
in um charter schools and transportation
um for them back to the home District or
for uh someone from the school to the
Charter School to perform the services
for that
child um so um in the first section
there it defines um School
transportation
vehicle and um modify statute throughout
including um at the end um on page three
uh section six we worked with the
Department of Education um on um adding
School transportation Vehicle drivers to
the um background check requirements in
in
statute um uh as I said we we spent
several hours over at DMV um working
with the several members um of the
department and the uh Trooper who is
primarily responsible for school bus
transportation um we went through all
the um administrative
rules regarding school buses and
transportation of students um with
representatives of the um uh company um
that we are primarily working with right
now um they are actually in 28 States at
this point um providing these
Services um so with that um I I offer uh
the amendment um I think it'll provide
greater flexibility for districts and uh
greater services for
students further discussion on the
amendment yes yeah thanks thanks very
much and thank you very much
representative cordelli for um for
putting together the amendment and for
the working um working together with
with safety on this but um you know I
know we've been um spending a little bit
of time this morning on on you know what
what amendments are ger language is
Germain and language is not is non-
gerain and um the uh you know the bill
is introduced and is heard basically
made changes to RSA
376a and
um focused in that area this is in a
completely different section of the law
26329 and it really looks like a
completely different bill now than the
one that was introduced and had a
hearing uh I'm not weighing in on the
merits of Representative Cornell's
Amendment here uh on the language but it
looks like a completely new bill and um
and I'm just wondering as to whether or
not we should get some um some eyes on
this represent Luna are you questioning
the whether this is a germine am I am
will
so okay so yeah thank thank you very
much Mr chair so so what I'm going to do
is I'm going to not go any further with
this at this moment we're going to take
a break from this particular Bill and
we're going to seek uh when we do
question the germanness of a bill it's
got to go forward to the speaker of the
house and has to have his making a
decision whether it parallels what the
bill initially looked like when it was
introduced or if there's a significant
change then it's called non gerain this
is not Senate where anything can be
added on uh so we will we will leave
this bill and we'll go to another bill
and we'll seek more information on on
the amendment I appreciate that thank
let me take this
fine going with the uh Bill we're going
to address next is HB 267 criminal
background checks is the basic
uh concept uh relative to criminal
uh represent cordelli was going to make
that
going to jump on to another bill then
seeing he's not here we're going to go
to next one 628 which um accepting funds
for performing background checks uh so
uh 628 requiring a certain non-public
schools or education service providers
that accept public funds to perform
background checks on all employees and
volunteers so represent dry you a motion
uh I move that it' be moved uh itl yes
sir a second a second okay
representative dry makes the motion to
itl Second by representative penell uh
representative dry yes um after a lot of
research um there's two sections to this
bill one is private schools having to
that get EFA money to
do the background checks um and the
other is uh home educated uh students
who become EFA students uh the first
part is
um in the state of New Hampshire private
schools have access to all of the um
background checks that the public
schools do Under the Adam Walsh act the
um the administrators of the public
school School non-public school uh
Association said that all their members
are there all the dases schools do back
uh background checks in fact every
school that I contacted in my district
there was a private school did extensive
by background checks to the you know the
full extent that they could do which
includes fingerprints um it's already
happening I think it's uh it's a
redundant bill in that section the part
going with home educated uh HFA students
it has a lot of questions because it's a
a home educated student becomes an an
EFA student when they be when they take
the EFA funds and even if we're talking
about things that are done in their home
as their home education study there are
a lot of out of home projects and
curricula that goes on and this opens a
large doors to who does the background
check who pays for it uh background
check has to be done by an agency it can
be done by an individual uh who gets the
results where are they shared and who
does anything with them I think it has a
lot of questions about it and therefore
itl representative Pell do you you made
the
second
okay okay any further discussion on itl
yes representa
Tanner um I'd just like to make a
rebuttal a short rebuttal one is that
private schools may may do background
checks um we don't know if new nonpublic
schools or or private schools coming in
are doing background checks there's no
no real
um repository of that um information uh
as far as I understand about a third to
two3 about a third to a half of the
private schools do do background checks
we don't know whether they're the same
criminal background checks that the
public schools
do um and if they receive public money
through the efas uh through tuition or
whatever um I feel that the state has a
compelling reason to require them to
have the same background criminal
background checks which go to a larger
extent for public schools um that they
should be doing that as far as the
homeschool uh issue is concerned um I in
my Amendment which um is to exempt uh
homeschoolers that are schooled at home
and the traditional homeschooling way so
um I think everybody I mean we're
talking about Transportation just a
little bit before and criminal
background checks were key to that I
think it's key to provide safety for
students um just about a week ago there
was an article in in-depth New Hampshire
about a woman who had been doing
volunteer work at a athletic event
selling food and and suddenly people
realized she was on the um sex offender
list um because there were no checks and
um I think that that puts Children at
Risk so I am going to vote against this
bill uh against the itl thank you thank
you very much representa Tanner
represent cordelli um thank you um I I
think there are significant problems
with um requiring um background checks
for Education Service
Providers
um um
there are Education Service Providers
such as as Staples that we've talked
about before but uh how about um going
to a museum where the CL class is
getting instruction possibly um you know
could be a courier Museum down in
Manchester Mcall of Shepard uh
Museum um Center um what about EFA
students who are coming for a state
house tour I see Mount Royal Academy is
coming in early December um they have a
number of students who receive
efas um it's everyone in the State House
going to be required to get a new
background check in order for these
students to um come into the state house
and get a tour
um I I I don't see any way around that
in in this legislation um in addition to
um it's a big problem I think uh um you
know we've talked about background
checks um a lot and we will be talking
about them further today
um because you get a background check
today doesn't mean that um there's not
going to be a problem uh next week with
someone who got that uh background check
we've seen that in our Public Schools
we've seen that happen um you know we've
seen teachers um in public schools have
their licenses revoked because of
similar
s similar circumstances thank you um so
I I cannot uh support uh this amendment
um or the bill we're not on the
amendment right now oh I'm sorry we're
on the bill we're on the motion as itl
okay I I'm supporting the itl motion
that thank you for the clarification on
that represent whitcock thank you
chairman lad just a couple questions to
follow up on President cordell's
comments I would suspect uh that when
folks go to the museum or come to the
state house uh they're in the under the
supervision of a professional teacher
who's already had a background check and
people in the state house uh giving the
tour the teachers accompany them when
they go to the museum the car museum the
teacher and staff is there so it's
really not uh an equal piece and I do
take um some uh
uh uh concern uh to just the end of his
conversation when he's talking about
what happen to public school teachers
what happen say it could happen tomorrow
I just don't like the way they that was
categorized as uh left there and a
negative thinking that's all thank you
further discussion on this bill ran luno
thank you very much Mr chair yeah I also
don't support the U the motion of itl on
this bill you know and I think the um
you know from from from the from a
public safety and from the for the
safety of our students uh the state of
New Hampshire has required for decades
now that prior to a prospective employee
being offered a um uh a position or
being hired uh in a in a school that the
uh the SAU the school district the
chartered public school or the public
Academy I'm reading from the statute
right now shall submit the criminal
history check record release form to the
New Hampshire State Police um which
shall conduct a criminal histories
record check through its records and
through the FBI the state police shall
examine the list of crimes constituting
the grounds for non-approval of
employment and it goes on from there and
we've heard uh um attorney Fenton from
the Department talk about the list of
disqualifying uh crimes and we've we've
we've certainly got members State Police
Department of Safety with us here today
um and thank you very much for the for
the work you do and and in in in in in
in really supporting job one in public
education which is keeping kids safe and
um and with with so much so many changes
going on here in New Hampshire with
respect to public education and across
the state um I think it's it's ever more
important that that that the legislature
and that the and that that we remain
Vigilant in making sure that this is job
one and when when I see you know
something being handed out from um uh
from uh handed out to this committee
with respect to prenda's background
check policy and prenda is a alternative
educational setting for um for
non-public as well as public students
public school students that basically
says um uh appena uses Checker a third
party company and covers the cost of
background checks on these adults
through Checker's criminal background
check premium service we run and they
list them off a County criminal search a
federal criminal search a national
criminal search a sex offender search an
SSN trace and a global watch list search
and um and and I think we heard some
testimony that a lot of these searches
are basically searches over the Internet
for things um they're not
comprehensive uh background checks
conducted by the state police nor
conducted by the uh by the F FBI and I
think if we're going to be putting our
kids um in educational uh uh uh
situations where um uh where they're
going to be with adults and those adults
should be um should
be background checked the same way that
we background check our um our our
adults that our grown-ups that work with
our kids in our Public Schools
and um and I I I I would certainly you
know uh if if if if what Checker is
doing is somehow equivalent to um to the
FBI um uh back criminal history check
then uh then you know maybe I'm missing
something but uhu but it certainly
sounds to me given the the requirement
that we have legislation that
specifically authorizes Criminal FBI
criminal history records checks that uh
that what's being done right now by
prena and by others is not sufficient
and that um and that the legislature um
really needs to act um uh in appropriate
way that that's reflective of the
changes that are being made in public
education today thank you thank you
leus I'm not sure how anything has
changed we've been dealing with this for
five years and we were supposed to have
a clearing house at the doe for people
who are not part of a institution that
the FBI will report to how are people
supposed to get this done if there's no
place that the FBI that they are
affiliated with it the FBI will do the
background check so it's really nice to
say let's do it but as far as I can see
we still don't have a method for doing
it so passing this is not going to make
any difference whatsoever we can't can't
do it so that was that was number one
and number two is the fact that most of
these um people who were homeschoolers
who are now EFA students parents are
there so if the parent is there why do
we need a background check on say the
music instructor or whatever the parents
are there so that's it thank you
represent vure thank you Mr chair I
think I just want to talk about the the
biggest thing that I've heard so many
times from people I've spoke to about
this bill and it comes down to it's
trying to accomplish too much at once
some of the things that this bill would
accomplish are not particularly
objectionable like private schools doing
background checks I mean it's I don't
see a big problem with that but then you
get down to the minutia some of the
other things that it does what happens
when you have a couple homeschool
parents who get together and they decide
maybe they're going to have a rotating
schedule where one teaches this day one
teaches the other day now you're
requiring a background check for these
parents and let's go further with that
what if a homeschool parent does have a
criminal record uh I mean criminal
record May disqualify you from being a
public school teacher it doesn't
disqualify you from being a parent so
what's going to happen are we going to
be in a position where we're telling a
parent they can't homeschool their own
child because they might have a criminal
record I mean it brings up some really
weird issues and we need to if we want
to do private schools we need to carve
that out as a separate bill thank you
rson Hall did you have your hand up
thank you uh I was just going to uh
reference the letter we got from Lori
Harman which was powerful enough for me
to think wow I mean I don't know if you
all remember that letter but uh she went
through a lot and so safety better safe
than sorry thank you we had just second
we had uh this bill went to a
subcommittee and you met on September
26th and October 18th representative
cordelli were any of these issues isues
discussed at that
time um I I think a number of uh issues
were discussed related to uh um uh
parents uh related to um non-public
schools and um educational service
providers for EFA
students um if I could could I just
mentioned uh non-public schools I don't
know if anyone talked about non-public
schools yet now go ahead thank you um we
had a uh a letter from the chair of the
non-public school advisory
Council um who pointed out that um
schools accredited by the New England
Association of schools and colleges um
require um background checks uh
non-public school approval by the
Department of Education requires
background checks to be performed he
also pointed out uh he is the super
attendent of schools for the diois and
pointed out that they have every school
employee getting a FBI background check
through the department of
safety um so I think that uh if we're
venturing into the area of non-public
schools um it's uh stepping out of uh
bounds um and it's already being done
we've had this discussion for multiple
years that it's already being done and
um uh there's been no change in that
regard and uh I don't see the government
mandating something that's already being
done in the private
sector further discussion yes
representative Woodcock thank you just
to follow by me Mr chair representative
bel's comment about the home schools um
and I agree with them uh Mike in terms
of the parent but I do have significant
concern when you're talking about
pooling homeschool schoolers that you
come over and I teach one week and you
teach the other I would surely want to
know that the person I'm sending my
children to uh has been cleared and if
they're criminal they can't pass their
background check just because they're
parent when they're one1 I have no
problem with that but when you get into
group settings like that and you're
sending homeschoolers to another set of
homeschoolers if I was a parent I'd like
to know that where that my youngster
going has uh that there is a if there's
a problem that has been cleared and been
checked that would be my thing but I do
understand the one one absolutely you're
right represent
dry thank you Mr chairman as a 30-year
homeschooler I'm going to tell you that
we either do it with someone we know or
we're there
watching represent representative
Damon I oppose the itl there is nothing
more important than protecting
children's safety perpetrators don't
have a Scarlet Letter or a gold star or
some visible indicator
of their
background you can live next door to
someone for decades and find them a
pleasant neighbor and think they're a
reasonable person and that does not tell
you what their history is and what they
might do we should be passing this bill
not
it further discussion from the committee
yes represent cascaden thank you just
want to go over some things that we had
talked about in the last time that we
talked through this bill um because it's
getting a little muddy in terms of
parents who are doing homeschooling with
their children but what I have as a
summary in the intent of this
bill is that it's to add accountability
to any non-public school Learning Center
or place that assembles children in an
organized declared or named educational
facility uh who receives education
Freedom accounts so a parent who's
homeschooling this in my interpretation
would not affect it but if there's one
homeschool
person that says okay I'll take six kids
and I'll educate them for
you that I have a problem with
so I don't know if that's how you're all
interpreting this but it's there are
Learning Centers I imagine around the
state people who have just open up shop
um and they need background checks again
safety is the big thing
here further
discussion represent
Miler not to prolong this conversation
but uh on the 26th when we did meet
there was a
differentiation of service provider
versus Goods versus
services so when we talk about the
Staples for example that's a Goods
versus a Learning Center which is a
service and this is really focused on
the service component of it not the
okay is there any further discussion on
this bill or on this motion on this bill
okay Madam clerk would you please call
the bill a motion on it 628 is
inexpedient to legislate that's which
we're we're voting on at this
time Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
Ford yes representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative Pell yes representative
corello yes representative Miler
no representative Cornell no
representative Tanner absolutely not
representative Luna no representative
Heath no Representative wock no
representative Hall no representative
Boni no Representative cascaden no
representative Damon
no chairman lad
yes 10 y 10
n so 101 no recommendation there
further represent Miler move off to is
there a second I'm seconding it pleas
okay so motion made OTP by
representative Miler second by
representa Tanner representa
Miler is this the point time to put
forward the
amendment pardon me could I put forward
the amendment at this
point yeah I can represent yeah I I took
you because you made the motion and then
okay so represent Tanner go ahead um so
2300h
um thank
you uh M representative Miler seconded
it yes we got that I'd like to speak to
it if I me yes go ahead thank you thank
you um there's two major changes in this
bill one is on line seven where it says
an employee or designated volunteer and
that that uh designated volunteer is a
term that's used in our rsas quite a bit
and it means volunteers who come on a
regular basis and have individual time
with students um that are not supervised
and the other one is
[Music]
in trying to see it is here um in
line
31 and it's uh this section shall not
pertain to parents giving a non-fa home
education program to their
children so it's uh the two two biggest
um things that people thought were wrong
with this bill initially um I can't do
anything about uh whether it's
government oversight or overreach which
is another thing that was brought up
consistently um I think it's oversight
when it's the safety of children um we
know that non-public schools do not have
to they are in the statutes it says they
may do a background check it's not um
put out put forward forward in the RSA
how those background checks have to be
done um and we know that there are a lot
of schools coming online now um that are
coming into the state of New Hampshire
and as I said as far as I could find out
only about uh between a third and a half
of the non-public schools do the uh
nesque um accreditation and therefore
have the background checks the other
ones um as far as we know will be doing
the background checks as prena so I
think this bill is necessary this
amendment cleans up the two major uh
discrepancies that were brought up and I
hope you can support the bill further
discussion representative penell yes
thank you thank you Mr chairman um
representative Tanner can you speak to
please um This was um put I'm sorry that
I didn't uh put that out but uh the
learn everywhere program was one program
uh that's been run in the state of uh
the state department and uh dealt with
students going out as uh represent
cordelli said like to um intern or
whatever uh in different places about
how they actually um dealt with the um
background check situation so that was
put in here to just uh approach what
would happen if um a student was
interning or going to a separate
um service provider I guess would
be represent cordelli uh thank you um
two questions actually first um on line
11 in relation to non-public schools and
um uh background checks line 11 says uh
submission of a history criminal history
background
check who is that to be provided to by a
non-public
school is that a question for
me well maybe I'll answer both questions
and then anyone one who wants the answer
at um May the second question is um in
relation to the changes on lines 30 and
31 that you just mentioned um I believe
it says a section shall not pertain to a
parent giving a non-fa student a home
education program how about a parent um
with an EFA student giving their child a
home education it seems like this would
person
so representative
Damon so in thank you in response to
representative cordell's second question
line 12 clearly says this shall not
apply to parents providing atome school
education so the parents who are not
part of the EFA program are clearly
this so representative McDonald thank
you Mr chair I think rep Damon just
noted a discrepancy between line 12 and
line 31 that the amendment has created
which seems to lead to some confusion so
the amendment appears to be unready at
this
discussion on the
amendment not seeing any Madam clerk
yes thank you I don't think that we have
answered fully the question a home
education program becomes an EFA program
when the home educating family takes EFA
money so they are not no longer
considered home education families they
are EFA student families so this would
not pertain would pertain to those who
do not take EFA it would exclude those
who do not take EFA money and do home
education but they're already
excluded this would make a category that
has uh home education at home a home
education program but they are
considered an EFA program because they
take EFA money I don't think this is
clear the law is very clear if you
receive the EFA money you are an EFA
student if you if you're a home
education parent not receiving any money
you are a home educator that's one of
the four stools for compulsory education
but you are correct that there is
a conflict here represent beler thank
you Mr chair and I would just pose the
same question I brought up earlier which
is if if we're going to be requiring a
parent to take a background check to
educate their own child at home simply
because they receive the EFA funding
what happens when they if they do have a
criminal record is the intent of this
bill and this this would be the question
is it to prohibit somebody from with a
criminal record from being able to
obtain EFA account to educate their own
home represent luno thank you very much
Mr chair um with with respect to um to
EFA students which which section one of
this bill is directed to uh I think the
conflict that you're referring to is one
of the one one that's artificially made
by proponents of of the EFA program and
that uh clearly in section one a
distinction is being made that that and
EFA
student could be attending a non-public
school or an EFA
student could be um at a could be a
homeschool education student with the
parents providing those services and in
section one this uh criminal background
check requirement would not apply to
those
parents of um that are that are
providing at school education for their
for their student I think that's
completely different than what's down at
the bottom of the amendment which um uh
which says this section shall not
pertain to a parent giving a non-fa home
education program to their children so
that's um that's completely different
language and um and applies to u to to
uh completely different
students representative cordelli thank
you but but in line 12 this shall not
apply to parents providing at home
education what if they do receive EFA
funding it's doesn't it say that it
should not apply to them as well
according to line 12 these are line
12 R Luna you
have further
discussion we're discussing the
amendment not seeing any Madam clerk
would you please call the rooll on the
amendment Vice chairman
cordelli no Representative leus no
representative Ford no Representative
beler no representative dry no
representative McDonald no
representative Noble no representative
Pell no representative Corella no
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative Luna yes representative
Heath yes representative wock yes
representative Hall yes representative
Balon yes representative cascaden yes
please chairman lead
no 10 y 10
days so we have a motion in front of us
right now on to pass on the primary bill
so not to pass that was put
forward so we're looking at six 28 HP
628 OTP is the
discussion Madam clerk would you please
call the
role Vice chairman cordelli no
Representative leus no representative
Ford no representative Belcher no
representative dry no representative
McDonald no representative Noble no
Representative peternell no no
Representative corello no representative
Miler yes representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
Luna yes representative Heath yes
representative wock yes representative
Hall yes representative Bon yes
representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad no
10 y 10 days so with this the motion
will go to the house floor with no
recommendation the octopath amendment
which was subject will go along with the
package everybody understand
that what do you mean
no it'll be printed in the calendar
it'll be printed in the calendars and it
will go forward when we discuss 628 on
the floor we will be also looking at the
amendment we that occurred last year
with a number of no recommendation
situations
okay and
M okay right and Mr chair um the initial
recommendation on the floor um will be
an aut to pass recommendation is that
correct that is correct that is correct
so who's writing the OTP represent
Tanner yes she is and who's going to do
it okay
cordelli uh thank you Mr
chairman um I would like to move uh
ought to
pass is there a
voucher yes if I could Celli offer a
further U motion and that would be uh
h
it
um I think I believe it had been passed
out um
was
two
distributed
no I guess we need copies made of that
2317 yeah okay this is a amendment was
put together by representative
Alexander presented to the committee
back when we were discussing the
bill so
do it was initially provided to us if
you don't have it we need to get a copy
for
everybody yes that was presented during
the last subcommittee meeting I believe
it was not submitted when the bill was
originally
okay at at the subcommittee that's
correct so everybody would not have a
then where's Jen she's got it okay okay
yeah you don't want my
copy okay so we will jump to another
bill
here
um okay we will jump down to HB 155
shity identification that deals with
private uh uh uh relative to higher
education commission uh hb1 155 does
here you
no
no and I would like to move on to pass
on
hp55 and we have a second from
representative Miler got
that okay I'd like to introduce hb1 155
Amendment it's
uh
245h
do everybody have that it just was
passed around
here
Sor I let's see thought we had second
you you I'll second I haven't introduced
it yet okay you second it okay the
amendment was introduced by myself and
second by represent my and I I'll go and
speak to the
amendment and the higher education
Commission as you well know there may
have been in the news that uh we had a
college in our state just this last week
uh discontinu uh the Magdalene I think I
that's University of College and student
population is relatively small but it's
a liberal Art School a Catholic school
and they're they're now um having to be
you know where those students go to and
where they attend this is what part what
the high education commission does and
they approve uh and of course and they
can have the option to disapprove a
univer postsecondary education here this
Bill had two parts to it and the first
part as you see on the amendment
committee
members there's on line 15 16 and 17 as
a result of our our study and our
recommending in in the committee process
that the individual the chancellor of
the University univers system of New
Hampshire be a member or his or her
designate the chancellor of the
community college system New Hampshire
we've added or
design and the commissioner of
Department of Education or design and
the commissioner of Education most
likely has a director of higher
education that would most likely be the
person but it's up to the commissioner
to appoint that you can see in lines 21
and 22 one member to be appointed by the
governor Council as a representative
from a for-profit college or university
not a member of the UN New Hampshire
College University's Council we have
none like that in the state right now so
it's
page and we had discussion when the bill
was first introduced what kind of uh uh
duties the commission can have and this
says the commission shall we at one
Point had the Kish Miss in May but we
struck out line four item four there on
line 13 apply for accept and expend
state federal or state other grants
that's been stricken from the bill the
the main part of the bill not the main
part but the next part of the bill which
was dealt with dealt with uh eliminating
everything to do with the fiduciary
indentification and all that uh of so
that's all gone so we're dealing with
just the higher education commission
here in this
amendment and this came as a request
from the Department of Education as you
remember the director was here and said
no just take that second part out that
was director
one the motion
is to approve Amendment
2450 and was second by represent Miler
any further discuss discuss on
cordelli yes representative leus yes
representative Ford yes representative
beler yes representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
Pell yes representative corello yes
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner
representative Luna yes representative
Heath yes representative wock yes
representative Hall yes representative
Bon yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad
yes 28 s okay we just approved the
amendment now we have a motion on the
Vice chairman
cordelli he he stepped out go ahead oh
okay we'll come back representative leus
yes representative Ford yes
representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative Pell yes representative
corello yes representative Miler yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
luno yes representative Heath yes
representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes representative
balbon yes representative cascaden yes
yes 19 y we'll put that on consent any
objections to doing that it shouldn't be
thank
you
let's jump down to
637 637 is relative to the calculation
of average daily membership and
pupils
can we take a five minutes to take a
five minute break to take a look at the
amendment yeah okay okay we're going to
take a five minute break everybody get
up and stretch walk the hallway if you
have to and we'll be back here to start
minutes
we're head over to the where we're just
gonna I thought you said to go the off
no no no no we're GNA go
over formerly HHS okay have fun yeah
yeah
okay I like to get us back to order here
so we can march on remember at 12:00 we
do have to break absolutely because we
have 12: 12:30 lunch and 12:30 onwards
we got this Ru making committee
so we're on HB 637 right now this is a
bill relative to the calculation of the
average daily membership and attendance
and average daily membership and
residence for certain home educated
pupils and I'd like to make the motion
here to ought to pass
second and so we have a motion made by
lad second by Myer ought to pass on
637 um can I offer further resolution
motion yeah okay I'd like to off offer
Amendment
231h this is an amendment for
637 and I'll leave it there and then I
can just talk about it a second and we
got a second from represent mil go ahead
um okay um what we have here is we have
a build in in the past we have uh
provided support for high schools that
are providing uh classes for those that
are coming in from homeschooling
environment and they get reimbursed a
0.15 FTE which is you know something we
put in effect years ago because kids
were going and taking a science class an
knowledge for class Etc and the school
was not getting any reimbursement
whatsoever for that we also had at that
same time this is years ago we were
discussing it and we're trying to figure
out how can we make this thing work for
other grade levels and some were saying
how can make it work even through the
elementary the grade schools and into
the junior high Middle School level and
high school it was very difficult to
deal with the grade school seeing that a
reading class starts maybe in the
morning and then sometime in the
afternoon when that particular group or
whatever goes on and you can't Define it
as a course uh like you can at the high
school level but in looking at since
then we know there's a lot of High
School courses taught in the Middle
School grades in junior high school we
also know many junior high schools
middle schools have block scheduling and
it's courses so there's no absolutely no
reason why we should not be
reimbursing the middle schools for doing
the same task grades seven and eight as
we're doing for grades 9 through 12 and
that's what this bill basically does it
allows that to occur so I won't discuss
it anymore we're on a short time frame
oh you handing it back to me no no
I are there further I'll hand it back to
Chairman Le and request the opportunity
to speak okay represent Tanner then
represent cordelli I'm just wondering if
this includes CTS do they do they get
homeschools schoolers coming in and do
they get
reimbursed the the hom School CTE
program as represent Cornell knows it's
the the the the funding for that is
based differently it's based on tuition
dollars and it is really a separate
different uh category Educational
Funding I do not know whether they get
that reimburse I know they
allow uh homeschoolers to come
participate in the CTE programs and and
uh they encourage it uh we should uh
however I I don't know if there's a
reimbursement honestly don't have an
answer for that one represent
Tanner represent
cordelli uh thank you excuse me thank
you um I think one important part of uh
actually the original Bill and this
amendment um is that it strikes um a
sentence from lines 21 and 22 in the
amendment in that the uh payments for
these pupils are subject to the
availability of Appropriations
so if there was money available the
school would get reimbursed if there
wasn't they wouldn't so this makes it
clear that it's not dependent upon um
available funds the school will get
reimbursed for these students which I
think is a very important aspect to this
bill representative Heath question on
that point so what you're saying then is
that the education trust um when
if in fact the education trust is very
healthy right now but if in fact it was
Zero at the at that point in time um the
um education trust would need to draw
from the general fund in order to do
that that's absolutely absolutely that's
struck and I think representative Tanner
asked a good question and uh you know
it's I I I believe that that's something
that we should communicate
representative Cornel and I to the
advisory Council and pursue that in
terms of for a student going to a Career
Tech
Center uh because they they're they're
being sent by the sending District
they're just not able to pick which CTE
they want to go to so there there's
there's probably an answer in this
somewhere and we we got to find that
out further discussion from the
committee so Madam clerk we have
amendment 2
301h with a recommendation ought to
pass Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
Ford yes representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative Pell yes representative
corello yes representative Miler yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
Luna yes representative Heath yes
representative wock yes representative
Hall yes representative Boni yes
representative casavan yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad
yes 20 y0 ma so we the next motion would
be to look at this bill in terms ought
to pass as amended HB
637 uh calculation of average daily
membership and attendance and average
daily membership of residents for
certain home educated student
pupils uh the motion is ought to pass as
amended represent cord
cordello Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
Ford yes representative elure yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative Pell yes representative
Corell yes representative Miler yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
luno yes representative Heath yes
representative wock yes representative
Hall yes representative albone yes
representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad
yes 20 A's zero A's so we'll put that
one on the consent calendar as well
let's take that one
up hopefully we can do polish that away
266 and 266 is relative to the
administration School assessment and
accountability programs by the
Education i' like to pass the Gabel off
to represent
cordelli uh yes House Bill excuse me
Senate Bill 266 do have a motion uh
representative lad yes I'd like to make
a motion of OTP
on uh SV
266 second second second from Mr Ford
representative Ford
um further motion yes I'd like to uh put
forward Amendment
2390 H
2390 for S SP
266 uh second to the
amendment motion second thank you okay
discussion yes um when we had 266 come
to us from the Senate this year it was a
very lengthy Bill and in fact I would
estimate at least 25 pages in that bill
and the bill came to us exactly as
introduced and the bill dealt with RSA
193e which is adequacy 193c which is
dealing with Improvement and assessment
uh RSA 193 H and
K and without any changes and yet there
were changes throughout that bill as you
you all know that when we looked at 266
and we had the side by sides provided to
us there are Mega changes within that
particular
sb266 and this what uh brings about this
this amendment is that the the bill we
met uh in Committee of whole a number of
times trying to address what we can do
with two 66 and we've had people coming
forth from the Department uh and uh uh
Katlyn Davis and Dr Nate uh green and
suggesting that we shrink that 266 down
to several Pages which are uh
referencing the needs to parallel what
we have in statute with what is required
by Essa element every student succeeds
act that we have done in this bill the
language all comes directly from the
Department with the exclusion of Page
Three lines 19 through
22 during the discussion we had as a
committee the whole there was some
discussion regarding when we contract
with a testing entity to do the annual
Statewide
assessment we have to send information
to them so that they can send results
directly to the
parent um this amendment right there
this amendment contains that along with
all the other suggestions that came in
from the state and it reads student data
shall not be disclosed by the testing
entity to any person organization entity
or government or any component thereof
other than the parent or the guardian
the department or the school or school
district and shall not be used by the
testing entity for any any other purpose
except as provided in RSA 193c colon 12
law that we have that's the change so
we're just trying to protect the da data
and and privacy and confidentiality of
of of the the student and family
information other than that uh there's
no changes which differ from um what was
presented to us I know that there's all
a lot of folks here which may you know
have concerns with a lot that was in 26
I think this was the Compromise where we
could get U language put forward that
dealt with Comprehensive support and
improvements of schools and dealt with
targeted support Improvement for schools
so we are paralleling now by doing so uh
federal law and
Regulation and also uh one of the
changes which occurred which uh
represent lad's not quite so infatuated
with but willing to go along with is
that the graduation
rate that's spoken to here it used to be
that uh when we had a rate this dropped
below
69% uh two consecutive years then a
school received support comprehensive
support uh it's now been dropped down to
67% for one year and that parallels what
we have in Federal Regulation so that
was done I personally would like to see
uh the credit graduation rate reflect
what our state is actually accomplishing
an average graduation rate of around 92
plus% which is a good reflection on our
state and there's a lot of uh conditions
which go into graduation rates as you
know some kids graduate in six years
others four years um some transfer out
graduate somewhere else some get the the
not the GED but the highet uh so there's
a lot of issues associated with that but
I think that this as it is right now is
is
a part of law that we really need to
parallel what we're what we're being
required to do so by the federal
government and allows us to give the
support to those uh that are receiving
funding for from
Essa that's
it representative mil yeah Ju Just a
technical question here um this bill
refers to
Essa so when another
Ed when another Administration comes in
and creates a program like every Child
Left
Behind I'm my ref the question is is the
reference to this specific federal
law in relationship to when this Law
changes with another legislation another
Administration what happens with this
language then when you specifically are
citing a particular law I don't know the
answer to that I'm just raising the
question about whether the
appropriateness of trying to
specifically cite a law rather than
federal regulations for example which
goes any you know I I I if you're that
maybe I tried to answer that for you um
I know that when we're we're looking at
Essa right now but if you look on page
four at the top of the page there how
the elementary and secondary Education
Act of 1964 5
Esa um and it's it's it's gone through
many revisions and changes obviously but
we're still talking about the esa you
know act so I I I've talked about that
with u with uh with Nate before and he's
always come back and saying this is in
if you look at other areas of Statute as
well we always reference as amended the
esa as amended so I I think we're
my yes yeah thanks thanks very much um I
was wondering if you could
uh comment on on page two um Roman 2 at
the top lines 5 through 7 um we're
adding a new a new paragraph that um
allows a um School District may choose
to participate in a local developed
alternative assessment program I'm I'm
trying to see how that
works where it where where where that
where Roman 2 continues as long as such
program or if such program is offered by
the department and approved by the
United States Department of Education
how is that look I'd be glad to respond
to that what this this language does it
really tightens it up for the Department
it used to be language and if you go go
back and look at this particular section
only it wasn't in the section two it was
they bounced sections around a little
bit that a local school district could
offer a different a Statewide assessment
and all they had to do in consultation
with the Department that's the way it
read the department has said that's not
that's in conflict with Essa and it's
caused a problem and we that came about
remember we had the old PACE program
and that we got a waiver for we got a
specific waiver for Pace but then we
also had if a school district has a
Statewide assessment let's say they're
using the Iowa Test of Basic Skills and
they don't want to use the Statewide
assessment they could go ahead and use a
test if it measured those Statewide
standards or needs and they could do it
and without with only consultation with
it they didn't have to have approval
this now says right here a school
district may choose to participate in a
locally developed alternative assessment
in place of the statewise if such
program is offered by the department and
approved by the United States Department
of Education so they're going to have
it's it's it's tightening this thing up
and it's taking that flexibility of the
local if they want to go that direction
and requiring them to get it it if the
state department and the state has
approved through a number of Grants
various ways to assess they could do
that but it's a real costly Affair so I
think what this the Department of
Education here in New Hampshire is
trying to do is get all people on the
same page and getting them to do their
Statewide assessment uh through the the
instrument that the state board has
approved okay thank thanks for that
explanation and one question yeah yeah
another another
question thank you
um on page four uh line 10 where we're
talking about CSI schools um these are
uh um schools comprehensive support and
Improvement schools um what what is
193e colon 3E what what is that
referring
to which line are you on or I'm on line
four the RSA site yeah some shall be
identifies as um a school in need of
corrective and Tech technical assistance
and subject to RSA 193 Eon
3-e what is that all
about I actually wasn't able to find it
online so does anyone have their
book it it's
193 3-
e could you could you read that to us uh
representative dve thank you it's a long
list corrective and technical assistance
and it lists um what happens in the
first year of a school being unable to
demonstrate it provides the opportunity
for an adequate education it goes on for
a long period of time about what happens
if that after a second consecutive year
and after a third consecutive year so
it's the process related to CSI it is y
okay and may I represent lad and that's
nothing new uh represent Heath you are a
commissioner of Department I'm sure you
well further
questions so I so just because this is a
very technical thing um so just
reflecting over to representative Heath
that's a reasonable um statutory
reference for a for a school that's been
found to be a CSI these steps have been
in place for a number of years um
actually before Esser even um probably
adjusted somewhat but it's it's
reasonable steps for school Improvement
basically okay I wish we had some money
that went with
it exactly um any further questions
related to the
clerk Vice chairman
we uh could we
a
okay cus over okay that was a quick Co I
record suspension is
lifted
suspens Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative Le
yes representative Ford yes
representative eler yes representative
dry yes representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
Pell yes representative corello yes
representative
Miler representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
luno yes representative Heath yes
representative wock yes representative
Hall yes representative Bon yes
representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad
yes 28 Z thank you uh further
motion I to pass amending yeah we now
have an amendment that's been a approved
okay uh so the motion that we're looking
at right now is ought to pass with
266 okay no Vice chairman
cordelli yes representative leus yes
representative Ford yes representative
Belcher yes representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
Pell yes representative Corell yes
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative
luno yes representative Heath yes
representative w yes representative Hall
yes representative bbon yes
representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman L yes
20 a z a thank you very much we are
going to take a break it's 12 o'clock we
will come back and start at
1:00 uh there will be a a meeting of the
subcommittee for rules that's
representative
Cornell representative luno
representative cordelli and myself and
we'll be meeting at
12:30 um I think what we ought to do is
try to find another place to meet so
that folks can come in and clean their
desks up
here we'll go across the hallway for
that group of
four yes is that last bill going on
consent yeah that would go on consent
thank you very much for reminding me so
what time you
yeah Jen can I get some stuff run off
for uh
this meeting coming
up you're gonna move your admin roles
group yeah yeah if we do that I just
need to let um media know because
stream change the
do then we'll have to do it here because
probably doable but I just want to make
sure that's accounted for well see yeah
I know it but
uh he for everybody here we're probably
going to have to do the 12:30 meeting
here because it's got to be streamed
okay yeah so we'll do it that way can I
get these things done for that um this
this is the ru making
notice this is the
that
e
to go ahead and start here and we're
going to start by tackling some of these
bills which are are of question now not
the none of the others we've done today
Schools
354 going to do the amendment
you do the amendment see what do I have
here
five4 uh who was going to do
it
okay I'd like to go ahead with uh HB
354 HB 354 uh a bill
here relative to Charter Public School
eligibility for state school building
Aid I recognized the time
McDonald thank you Mr chair I move that
HB 354 ought to
pass is there a second
second
okay for a number of years New Hampshire
chartered public schools have been
disadvantage in maintaining facilities
the passage of the bill would level the
playing field by allowing charter
schools to apply for state school
building Aid I'd also like to remind the
commit that enabling the application
process does not ensure building
projects will be funded but instead
creates a fair process for charter
schools and schools of the traditional
model this is an important step forward
especially considering that charter
you okay uh who did the second on that
represent
cordelli nothing further okay
I'd like to introduce amendment 2 354
and I hope I got the right one in front
of
me I'm just got so many amendments here
I've got
uh5 okay that's the one I've got uh I'd
like to introduce uh
24158 Sarah second
second
okay okay uh I'd like to go ahead and
speak to this um we this is a bill 354
we had 1 two 3 four
five committee as a whole during the
course of the last several months in
fact we had one back in
June and we're looking at the need for
charter schools which are public
schools to have the opportunity to apply
for uh Aid to construct or renovate a
building we also know that already on
the books we have a lease uh program for
them where they can receive funds for
their lease and I believe the lease it
can be up to as much as $50,000 am I
correct representa Heath thank you and
so we do have nothing though on the
books for the buildings which are owned
by the charter school and this bill
tries to address that seeing that we do
have some in fact we have some schools
which vary in size from maybe several
grades and in a small building to those
which are 500 more students in the high
school level and so there they there are
needs to try to make sure that our
public school students are in buildings
which meet all these codes fire Life
Safety health um have the opportunity to
acquire uh the areas of their education
their learning experience in a way that
is going to be um preparing them for the
future so the amendment which we have in
front of you at one point in time we
were looking at what happens if the
school dissolves what happens if they go
away for a voluntary or an involuntary
reason it doesn't really matter which
and they have taken money from school
building Aid uh funding through the
state as we have in law for other areas
of school building Aid any public school
that is closed within that 20-year
period has to repay back the monies
which have been forwarded to them for
their state for the construction or
renovation of that building unless
there's an extenuating
Circumstance the way this bill is
written right now in this am amendment
is that the the charter school will not
be receiving monies as a regular public
school does where they get 80% up front
and the other 20% of the state share
upon completion of the project the way
it works with this is that they will
receive 30% of the costs of the of the
construction but that 30% will be spread
over 20 years so they'll getting
incrementally each year X number of
dollars depending upon how much the
state share might have been it might
have been a million dollar may have been
a million and a half may have been two
and then of course then you can figure
that out by saying of that then that to
being 30% of the total cost of
construction it be spread over that 20e
period of
time so the amendment speaks to all this
and allows and and uses basically the
same language which is in law for other
public schools in terms of the criteria
they have to meet when they're
building uh they have to build of course
a code based the
standards um and then we've also added
in this
amendment what happens if a charter
school does dissolve and we have on page
five where it says Provisions for
dissolution of the Charter Public School
including disposition of assets or
amendment of its program plan that's
that's in place already but we we add in
there a Charter Public School may not be
eligible for a State Building aid grant
until the State Board of Education has
approved the school at schools asset
disposition plan what will happen in
case they do be due to voluntary
involuntary dissolution um close shop so
that is the nature of this it we think
it's only fair that that the Charter
School uh students have the opportunity
to attend a school which is you know
it's a state school it's state funded uh
that it also now meets all the standards
and conditions of the state so I'm
hoping that we will look at this lightly
and and and approvingly and and send the
right motion to the house floor thank
you um if if I could just ask you a
question of the representative um you
mentioned
30% um of the cost of construction
that's current law isn't it is it not
yes yes that is current that is current
law but the the the issue we have to
remember is that there's conflicting
laws in the statutes right now one place
you can receive the other place says no
you
cannot and so with that conflict this
bill eliminates that Conflict by
repealing on page
five relative to the prohibition on
Charter Public Schools receiving School
building a that is repealed so they
become eligible and they have to jump
through those same Hoops that everybody
else has to jump to and when you talk
about the total amount of funding that
we
provide you're could be looking at what
charter schools are going to receive
it's just a minuscule amount of the
Charter Public School funding that's
appropriated by the state hopefully
hopefully we can really up the Annie in
terms of what we are providing for
Charter Public for all public schools
because I understand and we've been
pushing for years that no less than $50
million be approved annually and as we
move away and pay off that tail that
debt which we have incurred we will have
more money for building Aid and of
course we got stacked up behind us a
number of school projects including
charter schools that need our support so
I hope we can move forward with
this uh represent
Woodcock thank you chairman cordelli um
Rick just this lad huh representative
lad right there next to represent
yeah but we're supposed to be using our
terminology here the representative from
hail New
Hampshire Rick I'm looking at the page
two 11 to 15 you're talking about uh I I
I just want try to be high time trying
to understand it if it says in line
13 that the annual Grant is shall be 5%
each year for 20 but then on line 15 it
says no more than 10% shall be
distributed until the complete
verification of the final cost so does
that mean that the payment
stops after the second year because
you'll be at 10% and then it picks back
up again I'm just confus I probably
reading it
wrong see what I mean yeah this this was
in the original bill as proposed um
that's okay if I'm
confused well that's okay you come from
Conway yes
sir okay um but originally from havil go
it so answer the I miss missed this me
look at
this if it's not done years you don't
get any
payments you get five get five a year
but 15 it says you can't get more than
10 till it's done not until it's
verified take two years so the
completion of the
construction line 16 says the completion
of construction if it takes more than
two years what happen
that's I'm saying you stop at 10 a
threee project we don't get it until
it's complete so you don't get five
year how long the project is well it
takes three years you only get 10% you
have to wait the first part says five
year for 20 years that's I'm just I'm
just confused that's
live I'm not going to comment on that
one right there because you know
[Music]
that we have a representative here that
submitted this bill may we could ask the
sponsor that you're so inclined
represent whitcock I'm
just I don't think an some clarity
doesn't matter who answers it
representative money do you have any
one being the she is the prime sponsor
of this
Bill thank you chairman lad thank you
members of the committee I know you've
spent ample time on this bill and I
appreciate your remarks prior to the
executive session for the record my name
is representative Morin money I did
Prime sponsor House Bill 354 I did Prime
sponsor the amendment which was the
exact language of 354 which was attached
to the house version of the budget pass
the house was taken out in the Senate
and as a side note I was also the prime
sponsor to raise the lease eight amount
to 50,000 so I appreciate that for
Charter Schools with that introduction I
don't have the bill in front of me so I
apologize for that if you could repeat
answer at one
point one
talks it's uh the point in question is
um on page two yes page two uh lines um
basically 12 through
17 we just trying to discern the
difference it says 5% a year for 20 I
got that then you move down a couple
lines further and it says until but only
no more than 10% until the completion of
the project so if it's a three-year
building project does that mean they
stop and then stop at the start again
because that would take four years you
don't that's the question I'm
just I believe that is a correct
interpretation and I will say this
section was
specifically
requested and suggested
by the Department of
Education so their managing of it would
language okay follow thank you so
basically then it it's it's kind of
contrary I mean it just starts and stops
in the regular school bilding aid that
doesn't occur is that
correct if you're asking me I it was
that's where the question
um if you look at regular public school
aid right where 80% comes to you the
other 20% doesn't come until completion
has been approved not just completion as
you see it but it has to be approved by
Amy Clark I'm looking at this right here
where it says not more than 10% of the
eligible amount shall be dispersed until
the completion of the construction right
so they're trying to get a h handle on
we are not going to disperse anything
until we have at you know that
completion approved then you can get you
know you can't get any more than 10%
beforehand uh but at that point you
can't get any more until you show it
it's
questions repres represent luno thanks
very much Mr chair um and so uh question
goes to um what representative l was
talking about with respect to the
disposition of Chartered Public School
Assets in the event of dissolution and I
was wondering what are the um uh what
are the minimum requirements for the
disposition of those assets that are um
354 is that for me yeah let me well I
put it out there for yeah and I I'll try
to respond to that because every school
bit district is going to be every chart
is going to be somewhat different and
and when you set up these agreements and
you accept these dis disposition
agreements they are going to be
different based upon a lot of different
factors dealing with uh resources that
are available to them size of school and
on it goes local so rather than write
down specific criteria here um um to
Charter Schools since um
uh since the local taxpayer would be
responsible for paying back the state in
the event a public school facility is no
longer used what is the um what is the
the the the similar thing uh uh for
charter schools that would require the
the charters um board to repay back the
state in the event the um the charter
were to dissolve and I believe we did
hear that in the
what is it two decades we've had charter
schools here in New Hampshire that a
handful of them have have dissolved so
we know for a fact that that history has
told us that Charter Schools do in fact
uh dissolve not aware of any public
schools that have um have have dissolved
but um um but I'm just wondering you
know what is that what is that
requirement where's that laid out for
Charter since we do have it in place for
public public school right um if I could
respond um uh I I think we also heard
that uh with those um charter schools
that have uh dissolved uh there has not
been a problem with um any of those uh
schools um and the uh Return of the
assets um and in this legislation on
page five it says in order to be
eligible for the aid the disposition
plan has to be updated
uh to accommodate uh the school building
Aid so the
disposition um plan must be updated in
order to qualify for Aid um and I um did
talk to um the
uh deputy director of the charitable
trust unit of the Department of Justice
who uh I talked to him should um it be
in the
doe um statutes
or in the doj because um any charter
school has to file with charitable trust
as
nonprofit and as part of their articles
agreement they must also have a
disposition plan in their articles of
agreement and he did not think that
um um the section that we were looking
at in the doj statutes would be
appropriate he thought that uh it would
be more appropriate um in in these areas
so so where follow up to go ahead to you
um um representative cordelli where in
354 this goes back to my original
question um where does it lay out what
those minimum standard minimum
requirements are for disposition of
assets um uh following a a charter
dissolution I understand that the that
doj requires that of all non not
for-profit uh entities uh registered in
the state but um and that while you say
there's never been a problem with
charters in the past we've never had
building Aid we've never had State
taxpayer money going to uh to to fund
assets uh of a um of a charter this
would be the first time with that and in
fact we have seen what at least one
charter dissolved because of financial
mismanagement um substantial Financial
mismanagement
so so there have been problems with
Charter Schools there have been problems
with with um with dissolution and how is
the state going to be protected from
ending up holding the bag State's
protected for public schools how's it
going to be protected in this case the
the uh charter school has to annually
with the charitable trust report their
audit and their audit includes their all
their assets and it can be anywhere from
books supplies motor
Vehicles Furnishings equipment
facilities property and those are those
assets as in any audit when you're
listing your expenses your revenues and
your your assets is an annual Affair and
so with that those are the portions the
elements which can that contribute to
that disposition plan that we are
requiring that they
have and it's going to be different for
each particular charter school but uh it
it it's I think it's pretty clear that
that there going to have to Pro pay back
only that portion of the school building
Aid that they have received we're not
looking at getting a chunk out of you
know their return value for property or
facilities or Tex or
vehicles uh we're looking for
reimbursement of only the state aid that
they have received and if it's in
many of these Charter Schools not many I
I won't say that I'll say those that
have not that aren't here that have
dissolved how many years did it take
well you know after three or four or
five years well after three or four or
five years of receiving this amount of
money which they're receiving I I figure
it's pretty minimal in terms of if
you're talking only 30% of the the cost
of the project and then you're looking
at 5% over those years going out you're
not looking at significant dollars and I
believe that the other property value
and all that other assets would
certainly cover it so so where does it
say in here that those that those
taxpayer monies would get paid back to
the state not looking for more than that
but where does it say in here that that
that would happen it would be within
that disposition
plan or not it doesn't say that the
that
certainly not required by the
doj if I could read from the uh
testimony that we receive from the
charitable
trust
um the dissolution clause in the
Articles of agreement must provide that
upon dissolution the organization will
distribute its assets to another
nonprofit or government
entity
that
doesn't represent Woodcock then
represent Heath thank you chairman Le
represent C I like to go back if I may
go back to the the uh lines two three
and four and page five he intimated that
when you said when you spoke about that
explaining that part of of the uh change
in the amendment that that would they to
go back and and file a new asset
distribution plan but it was my
understanding that the initial asset
asset distribution plan was filed with
doe when the sh of school applied and
this doesn't say anything about A
Renewed disis plan I me they when they
file that their the 5164 638 and when
the doe approved the charter they approv
the initial distribution plan and that's
all this is and and unless I
misunderstood I thought you said in the
updated one I don't see nothing here
that says that the updated included the
if I might um on those lines it says in
order to qualify for the building Aid
yeah they have to um show the asset
disposition
plan doesn't say upgrade it doesn't say
update doesn't say new
uh I I think that the department can
look at the current disposition plan
anytime they want but in order to and
it's available to the public um but in
order to qualify for the building Aid it
has to reflect the uh the new situation
um in the disposition plan doesn't say
that I it it does to me it doesn't say
new I see I don't see new there it says
or amendment of its program
plan on three two three and four the
change doesn't say new it's the same
it's the same almost the same lines that
does in the initial Charter School
approval that you have to have the plan
that's all just
I hear what you're saying yeah but it
doesn't say it that's all I hear I hear
how you're interpreting it why if the
disposition is plan is required in order
to get a charter correct right so if
it's um required to get schooled
building Aid why would you even add this
uh because there is already a
disposition plan if it's a charter
school there's already one so if you
want to get building Aid doesn't it uh
follow that you would update the uh
disposition plan in order to accommodate
for the school building Aid you're
receiving I think that makes perfect
sense represent cell but it doesn't say
that it does it doesn't say update
doesn't say new I agree with you the
thinking is logical but it doesn't mean
it's right it's not here it's not in
print oh I think my thinking was logical
and right I'm not surprised that
either okay represent he
um not many Charters are owned the
buildings are owned I think there was a
handful of them um this is very
unchartered
territory um and I
honestly I I have mixed feelings about
it quite frankly because our Charters
have provided a lot of wonderful things
but the thing
is the way this bill is specified if I'm
buying a if I'm do asking for building
Aid and then I'm getting money over a
period of 20 years
years just the whole the way the whole
thing is set up is is difficult then I
really do think I think um
representative Woodcock has a really
important point when we get
building when we get building Aid
there's a plan and and Amy is checking
on the manner in which that gets spent
when you get building Aid you don't get
everything you want you get what she
approves only it would be the same thing
with the charter they would get only
what she has approved but in fact there
needs to be some kind of in any good
business if you're dissolving you need
to get have a plan not just assets how
do you repay that money back to the
state if your building is dissolve if
the charter is dissolved I just I think
there are a lot of you know I'm I'm
gonna I have no feelings about should we
do this or not I'm I'm mixed about it
I'm ambivalent but I think this bill as
written needs some work I think some
things need to be sorted out and spelled
out better I mean just from my coming
from the finance committee this could be
confusing and I don't think we can make
assumptions about what's going to be in
an asset plan or what's not we have to
say especially when we're giving
building Aid we've never done this
before we need to spell it out correctly
minute she has she's been working with
us on and supports the idea that even
the concept the intent that Charter
Schools receive this there's a lot of
different legislation out there from
state to state and how they do this we
prefer to write the in fact in working
with the dissolution committing on
Charter Schools the way we initially had
it because we were saying you got to put
put up some kind of a bond you got to
put up some indemnification Bond you
have to put up an escroll account you
whatever it might
be and it was decide no that's not the
go that's right and there are assets and
when we had the charitable trusts coming
in testifying it and saying hey that
they are accountable for audit to the
charitable trust not the Department of
Education and
and and so there there's a process in
this law in fact even ends up in the
courts and for the disposition of of
assets that can happen it can happen
with any type of
organization however when we're looking
at the assets and we look at the types
of assets these uh these charter schools
have and the amount of money they're
receiving here the that would cover what
they've received in State Building eight
or renovation
yeah yes representative
cascad thank you just um looking for a
little bit of claric clarification so I
can understand this whole picture so far
I understand what you've been presenting
my experien is with North Country
Charter Academy serving on a Board of
Trustees two sites Lancaster
Littleton they apply for building Aid
they get awarded it they're going to
renovate a
site
do the voters of Lancaster and Littleton
both vote on that approval of that
construction project
or even if it's in a single town do the
voters vote on whether that's a project
or not because I believe any other
public school the voters it would be the
trustees of that Charter seeing that the
charter you're talking about has seats
available from numerous school districts
in fact I am in one of those districts
yep yep and so that it wouldn't be
hail's obligation it wouldn't be
Berlin's obligation it would be that of
the trustees of that Charter School not
where it's
located not not not the resident
District of not Littleton right okay so
the voters do not have the say of
approving a construction project are
not right the the approval is done by
the state
board right so the initial approval to
apply would be your trustees okay got it
yeah thank you yeah yes just a question
on that so you are saying that
the board or the trustees of that
Charter are taking on the
liability for that
loan
or for that building a grant yes and
they've been doing that according to the
charitable trust that's what they are
because that's their organizational
structure but they've never had money
from the state
before in well they've had Grants
awarded that's right not building Aid
per se yeah Federal grant money has
started these things up and state
Appropriations all right but but I think
representative Cornell was next I just
had a question about if once we've on
this bill if if it passes does it go to
another committee like does it go to
finance or anything to be reviewed for
the financial parts of it the answer is
yes uh the
there we we we're talking about a number
of bills here which have dollars you
know for example if we were looking at
the uh reimbursement for Teacher
shortage and all that for looking at the
one and a half to from three and a half
on cat a you're talking certainly that's
they're all going to trip down towards
Finance or a second Committee of some
kind I would represent Lun so thank you
very much Mr chair I just want to
clarify something I I here and make sure
we get it on the record so is there
something in House Bill 354 or anywhere
else in the law or anything in the doj
policy that would hold the trustees
personally liable for um uh for State
Building Aid should the
be dissolved within the 20-year
period I I don't know I I know of
nothing it was implied that there was
that there was liability by the trustees
and I'm just I want that's a very
important thing because anybody that's
owned a business and has co-signed a
personal guarantee to a to a commercial
loan understands what that what that
personal liability is I want to know for
the record if the legislative intent of
liable that would not be my
view so is your view different than what
representative
lad it sometimes
is thank
you yeah he's he's a southern boy I'm a
northern
boy represent
Tanner so if the trustees are not liable
uh held liable then who is who and I
guess we're back to the same question
when I look up if a if a normal charity
just a charity goes bankrupt um you know
they go into receivership or they the
you know federal government comes in
takes over we this is a kind of a unique
situation um because they are nonprofits
and they are with a charitable
organization registered with them and
yet they kind of are with the
doe um and we're using taxpayer money so
we've got a nonprofit receiving taxpayer
money um and I just you know again just
coming back kind of circling back so who
is liable who who's on the hook for this
you know I let me just respond to this
because I think we can go on forever
here with this type of questioning uh
however I'm looking at this strictly as
we're at to do so as a policy issue do
we believe that we want to have all
students in structures which are
satisfactory and meet those minimum
standards Public School approval and and
it this most likely would go to a second
committee and these are the type of
questions for the second committee which
are dealing with dollars and
liability and and how we ensure that the
state's not going to remain on the hook
uh but that's not a question for this
committee at this time this is do we
believe that charter schools are are are
better supported through funding from
the state in terms of renovation or
construction building Aid I personally
think yes now whether we can you know
afford it or do it that's going to be
decision CH yes so thanks I'll I'll I'll
put a comment out in a in a different
direction too than what than what we've
been talking about but with over $200
million in um in uh building Aid
requests by by public school districts
so now we're talking about taxpayer
owned taxpayer funded uh Public Schools
$200 million worth of um worth of
projects I think it's important that we
use taxpayer money to uh to reduce the
burden for our taxpayers and uh
and and I I think given the fact that
we've had a 10-year um moratorium on um
on building Aid that that we need to get
back to business supporting our um our
our taxpayer um and our our public
schools and not uh not um you know
private non-for-profit um schools thank
you I would just say I
think for me this bill um Prim primarily
resolves the one remaining conflict that
we have in statute uh between different
areas in Statute in that in one area
this says Charter Schools shall receive
um building Aid and in another it
doesn't so if you know we'll be all set
with our statutes if we resolve this one
remaining
issue okay rep representative
Ford I'd like to introduce just maybe a
slightly different perspective I don't
know if you've ever had the unfortunate
opportunity to close down an institution
like a school but I have and one of the
things that happens is there's no money
left there's no money to pay anything
and if all you have is a building then
you fall into the legal wrangling
over who this person's liability this
person's salary at etc etc and then all
that all gets eaten up in
litigation so you wind up with those
expenses piled on top of it it would be
much simpler if the goal of this
committee would simply resolve this
issue by simply saying this must be
bonded and the bonding will repay the
state should this institution fail then
you're done otherwise you're going to
wind up in this cely you're in right now
you can't get there from here but the
money won't be there I can promise you
that I've seen it
go and when it's gone it's gone is the
saying
has so there won't be anything to fight
over regardless of who really deserves
what it'll be a lot better if you make a
decision Bond it fine make them buy a
bond and that's the end of it but that
way everybody's liability is
limited you know I I'll speak to that
because I totally
disagree
that when we're starting about a charter
school we're talking
startups and if you're trying to say
well we're never going to have a charter
school because they're never going to
have the money for an escr account
they're never going to have the money
for a letter of credit they're never
going to have a bond and they're never
going to be able to have a deed of trust
and if you don't have these things in
place how are you ever going to have a
charter school and I've been around here
for a while and seen charter schools
start and I've seen one charter school
situation where we had $10 million
sitting here that we had appropriated
for it and the state refused to use
those $10 million and they had already
put out a lease and we're already in
debt and you know I I think that if
we're not going to recognize the value
of charter schools and what they're
providing we all know that one school is
not always going to be the best fit for
a child and this is an opportunity for
us to support this concept where we're
looking for every child succeeding with
their learning process so you know it's
it's a it's a difficult issue yes but I
think we can Wade through this other
states have done that and some states
that are have more students involved
with it and and and and maybe go the the
direction you just mentioned representa
Ford but those those options we looked
at in the
dissolution committee and we looked at
one specifically the bonding and that
was decided no that's not a direction we
should go and that's why it's
out represent
Miler I'd like to call the question
please
good I think it's a good
idea any further
discussion one more and then that's it
represent beler thank you Mr I'll be Qui
I just wanted to to lay out that I spoke
to uh somebody I know who was a school
board member in the North Country a
while back and it really gives truth to
the idea that there there is also um
liability for not liability is not the
right word but there's risk
involved in public schools of All Sorts
he was talking about this school that
they built they spent a ton of money on
it and it turned up over a period of
time they lost population so they wound
up a build a building bigger than they
needed which is now costing them extra
money because they have to do upkeep on
a building bigger than they need with a
smaller population so I think it's
important that we recognize that in all
forms of public school whether it be the
traditional government style or Charter
there are risks to the state that we
consider acceptable because we consider
a charge to educate children because
that's that's what we're doing thank you
thank you okay we're going to call the
question right now we have an amendment
on the on the floor right now it's h uh
2415 H for HB
354 Madam clerk will you please call the
r Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
Ford yes representative beler yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative peternell yes
representative corello yes
representative Miler no
representative Cornell no representative
Tanner no Representative luno no
representative Heath no Representative
wock no representative Hall no
Representative bbon no Representative
cascaden no representative Damon no
chairman L yes 10 y 10 y so we'll go on
with the next motion that motion dies
1010 and we'll go on with the motion we
have on the floor for HB 350 before
that's ought to
pass is there any further discussion
Madam
clerk Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
Ford yes representative beler yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative Pell yes representative
corello yes representative Miler no
representative Cornell no representative
Tanner no representative Luna no
representative Heath no representative
Woodcock no representative Hall no
representative bon no Representative
cascaden no representative Damon no
recommendations I'll make motion of
itl second okay we have a motion made by
represent luno and second by represent
Myer the motion is itl uh represent luno
your right to vote represent Miler same
further
discussion when you're ready Vice
chairman cordelli no Representative leus
no representative Ford no Representative
elure no representative dry no
representative McDonald no
representative Noble no representative
Pell no Representative corello no
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative luno yes representative
Heath yes representative wock yes
representative Hall yes representative
albon yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad no
ten
tenes okay on the uh writeups for this
committee report
Valerie representative McDonald might
motion yeah you can make motion I would
move to interim study this
please first no no no no
no represent could the chair repeat the
motion please the motion is interim
study put forward by whom or represent
Miler yeah thank you
and is there a
second
second represent Damon excuse me who was
the second on the previous motion of I
Miler represent
[Music]
M I'll I'll speak to my motion okay go
ahead you know this obviously this is a
we spent a lot of time on it and there's
a concern about the whole issue of U
school building Aid in general and uh
this has another component to it and I
just think it might be have some value
to at least keep it in advance uh so
that we might be able to have further
look at it uh particularly as uh as
chairman lad has said as we begin to
look at the uh tail being paid off and
if there's more more funds that are
going to be available as that is done it
might provide more resources than for
for building Aid and I just think it
might be a good idea to kind of just
keep it out there and not just uh put it
to a potential being killed uh on the
floor by whoever shows up on that
particular
day okay I'd like to speak to the motion
to on June 12th September 14th on
October 5th on October 18th and October
31st we've been discussing this
bill and as a policy I think uh it comes
out fa clearly to me that some are
supporting moving forward with this
legislation and some are not
and I I I think at this point in time
yes it been wonderful to send this to a
second committee that could have had a
an answer maybe some of the issues which
we talk about in terms dealing with a
charitable trust dealing with Finance uh
those are issues I think most of us all
recognize there may be still some issues
that need some
resolution but in fact to keep that in
this committee for an interim
study where I don't believe we have all
the you know
the the angles represented at this table
other words represent Heath you're here
from Finance you have some
understandings what's going on in
finance whereas many of us are not part
of that although we do attend uh I am
not supportive of interim study on this
bill I I feel that it's time to take it
to the house floor and present present
it to our whole body and see where we
are with it um it it's something that I
think is is critical it's it's a top
priority to myself this bill right here
of all the bills we're looking at today
it's the one that's the one that's most
important to me building Aid whether it
be for a rigger school or a charter
school is important it's if you don't
have a decent building you're not going
to be able to provide the education
that's necessary we've seen that new
construction new buildings clean
buildings the achievement scores of kids
are at least 15 percentile points
higher you're not going to give the
charter school kids the chance I think
that's appalling and I'm I'm I'm really
uh sad this committee is where it is on
vote Vice chairman
cordelli
no Representative leus no representative
Ford no Representative beler no
representative dry no representative
McDonald no representative Noble no
representative Pell no Representative
corello no representative Miler yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
luno yes representative Heath yes
representative wock yes representative
Hall yes representative Bon yes
representative cascaden
yes representative
days okay so we we got to move on here
just a inquiry Rick y yeah um so we've
had three votes all 1010 what goes to
the floor OTP right will be the first
motion what is the um what is the other
motion that would would be reported out
I think that would be your choice if you
want interim study or it or um itl I
would support I um well I I mean I don't
know what what would you like to report
out itl report out itl
absolutely
yeah could could um you guys fight it
out yeah yeah okay we'll let you know
all right okay representative lad will
be I mean represent will be doing the
rep okay okay for the time being um just
handing the sheet off at the end of the
day indicating that the two Mo the two
positions will be ought to pass an itl
and you can get back to if there's any
difference
yeah
okay what we're going to do right now is
move on to um HB 623 teacher loan
forgiveness program
Mr chair I would move to interim study
this I'll second it I'll speak to that
speak to it now okay in in the spirit
since we have uh 12 more more bills to
consider this afternoon uh I think it's
time to move this along uh there is a
bill first of all I need to apologize to
the committee because this bill is not
what I thought it was going to be and I
was away and did not have a chance to do
the due diligence that I should have
done done so I apologize the committee
to that there is a bill coming forward I
believe from the Senate which is very
similar to this 217 Senate Bill 2117
which will give us an opportunity to
look at it at that point in time so at
this point in time I just move to move
it to interim study at this point in
you okay I I have no further discussion
on it either is there a further
discussion from the
committee Madam clerk when you're ready
can we call the roll on it
that's 623 the motion is for inum
study Vice chairman
cordelli yes representative leus yes
representative Ford yes representative
Belcher yes representative dry yes
representative McDonald no
representative
Noble yes representative Pell yes
representative cor yes representative
Miler yes representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
Luna yes representative Heath yes
representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes representative
bbon yes representative cascaden yes
representative
Damon
no chairman lad
yes 18 y two Nays any objections to
putting it on
consent Minority Report no okay we'll
[Laughter]
education
me yes she
okay did she send it around earlier no
it
okay I want to make sure I got my stuff
together here um I'm looking at three
amendments one from represent Tanner
0222 is that still good uh no no that's
no good
okay well maybe good but okay one from
representative cortelli
0205 H is that still
good I will I will not offer that in
Defence to this new Amendment okay so
that's two out of three that I have
let's see if I got else I got
it there was one which we had 2309 from
represent cordelan katab is that good or
bad probably not I I will also not offer
that in difference to this one and we've
got one here from representative leus
2456 that
good okay it sounds like it's good um
there so we're looking at that one okay
so that's one in front of us now we need
to get a motion
here
uh where are we
identified I'll make am okay represent
Cordell you recognize for a motion uh
pass sir a
second okay represent
leus represent cordelli you're
recognized
you want to pass and just go to the
amendment uh yes
please okay repent leus I'd like to move
um passage of amendment
[Music]
24568 sir a second Peron dry Peron leus
okay so what I've done for this
amendment we had a awful lot of
conversation about the committee being
too big and how we could manage that and
how we could reduce it and so
representative dry and myself and um one
of the people who had come in one of the
public who had come in to help who had a
lot of information on this sat down at
lunch and went over all of the things to
try to figure out just what was required
by the federal law and we came up with a
list and that if we only do what's
required by the federal law that's 25
people that comes
to I have added this just takes that
plus two additional one would be the
member from the um home school because
that's been in state law for a while and
that was on all the Amendments everybody
agreed to that one and that way all
students require regardless of what type
of school they go to have a
representative so that was just to make
sure because the federal government
doesn't have it in cuz not all school
not all states are allow
homeschool so um but we do so I left
that in and the only other thing that I
put in was the health care professional
who deals with children because that was
the whole point of the bill that was why
it was introduced and we all agreed on
that everything else I took
out um doesn't mean they can't be there
it's a public it's a public public
committee if Representatives want to
show up they can show up if pic or some
of those other people want to show up
they can show up but they're not part of
the membership so nobody's counting on
them I did put uh one non-voting member
I we talked about making lots of people
non- voting members which I didn't want
to get into but we had also talked about
um a member of the de e for technical
support like making sure the zoom
meeting was working Etc and so I
couldn't figure out how else to put them
in to make sure they came but I didn't
want them to be part of the membership
so I did say non- voting member but I
didn't really want to get in a non-
voting member um but I wanted to make
sure they show up anybody else is
optional so we're not saying those
people can't come and we're not saying
they can't participate we're just not
making it part of the membership so they
can come if they want to or not it's up
to them um so basically this is just the
minimum and it comes to 29 people which
is much better than the 40 something
that we had in there so that's this is
just barebones amendment to try to get
the absolute minimum number of people
who have to be
there represent luus how many parents
are on this now vers how many total
members in the committee there's um 14
and 14 there's
14 there's 14 members who are who can be
parents there are 14 members otherwise
and the other one is um one individual
with disabilities who may have received
special education services and who may
be a high school student appointed by
the governor and I and that was
originally separated out then it got
included into the first part and the
problem with including it is you could
have all parents and not have any
special ed um any individuals with
disabilities so the federal had it as
separate and I put it still as separate
but it counts in the it counts in the
parents and special needs number not in
the regular member number so I'm a
little confused yeah so we're we I can
remember talking to I don't remember
which attorney but saying you couldn't
be a parent and a representative in some
other category well no that's not what
I'm saying the point is the first we had
combined the federal had two separate
sections and we had combined them into
one that says individuals disabilities
or parents of children but you could
meet that requirement just with parents
but the point was there needs to be one
individual with disabilities who's a
member and the federal had it separated
out I separated it back out but it
counts in the total of majority of
committee membership composed of
individuals with disabilities or parents
of children with disab the toal voting
membership is what 29 29
okay and 14 are parents no 14 are
parents or people with disabilities one
is someone with a disability and 14 are
the other members and that's just to put
it back the way the
federal wanted it it could be zero
parents it could be 15 people with
disabilities
yeah it's just it got separated out to
ensure that at least one member has
disabilities which is the way it was
originally in the the federal
representative bbon you have
hand um yeah I'm on the commit thank you
chairman lad um being on the committee
I've have heard a lot about the
dysfunction in the committee and a lot
of the reasoning behind it and it seems
pretty clear that there's not a lot of
support um that's being given to the
committee in terms of administrative
Technical and
organizational um I apologize I was not
able to be here at the last meeting when
this was discussed but I think it's
important to note um that there's an
audit currently being
conducted and and part of that audit is
looking at this particular committee the
audit is being conducted by the office
of legislative budget assistant and the
results will be published in the spring
my concern um because we keep coming
back and we keep changing the
composition and looking at is that let
let's do this the right way let's wait
until we get the results from the audit
which I believe are going to have pretty
clear
recommendations on perhaps the
composition but at the bare minimum what
needs to be done to get this committee
uh with a very important Mission by the
way to function the way it's supposed to
so I won't be voting for any amendments
I really think that we have to step back
and put it into an interim study and
wait for the results of the thank you
just for those that are new on the
committee a performance audit is done by
the
LBA and it is that a situation which may
be really needing an investigation and
the LBA legislative budget Assistance
Office does this thoroughly and we did
this with the
um uh special education advisor wasn't
it or the um there is a a Department of
Education special education audit
performance audit yeah performance audit
as well and so that's that's under way
as well and this is news to me represent
valon and
uh yeah
so yeah what could I call
verify is is have you received on your
committee any kind of contact from the
LBA that they've already started started
this
audit um yes the audit has already begun
the observations have already been made
um the next steps up are the uh
committee is going to be talking to the
various representatives and giving them
an opportunity to respond and I believe
that will occur in January and February
and then taking that feedback back they
will produce a final report I think in
April and report back at that time thank
you further discussion represent Hall
I agree with representative Bon but I'm
also curious I have a question for
representative leas on the when we had
the testimony heard the testimony pick
in the DRC wasn't she totally in favor
of having them on and how did they get
off I'm just curious um she was totally
in favor we heard from lots and lots of
parents who were not in favor we've
that's been because that was one of
those controversial issues and some
wanted and some didn't I didn't put them
on they're welcome to show up as it's
public right they're not membership okay
I was just wonder because you had talked
about she was things that everybody
agreed on except
her not well I didn't know if I had have
known I would have never put an
amendment in no okay thank you I didn't
mean representative bbon I metant the
woman who
testified yes represent Miler thank you
I I want to thank representative alone
for the information I think clearly
that's very important for this committee
to have I do have a couple questions
though for uh representative
Lakers during the testimony the as I
recall one of the frustrations of the
people who are on the group right
now is the issue of oversight on the
part of the department support on the
part of the department funding on the
part of the department believe they were
talking about the need for some training
some professional development if you may
Etc and I so my first question is why
wasn't there some recognition in your
amendment to deal with that
administrative and funding piece that's
my first question I've got a second one
after that well I did that was the point
of um oh one non-voting State education
official from the Department of
Education appointed by the commissioner
of Education to serve in a technical
support role and I didn't spell out what
technical support it could be any of
those things it could for all of those
things and it could be setting up it
could be setting up the zoom meeting I
mean it's whatever is needed the second
question is um I noticed that the
disability rights Center and the uh
parent information center is not in here
why are they excluded from well that's
what I was just saying because we heard
from people who wanted them we heard
from a number of parents who did not
want them because they were one of those
um controversial members and so I just
tried to put the bare minimum and they
member representative
Tanner thank you um I can't begin to
tell you how many hours I spent on this
on the phone phone with different people
um because I was in charge of making the
First Amendment for it and unfortunately
I was not able to make the um retain
Bill committee meeting on it uh when
representative leus was given the
commission of going back to Bare Bones
right so um just my conclusion is uh
from everything i' all the input I've
had what I've tried to do people I've
talked to is exactly what representative
balbon said that the this committee that
functioned very well before coid
functions terribly right now um some of
it is due to uh the person personalities
that are involved in the committee and
as I said to many people legislatively
we don't deal with personalities and we
can't fix that kind of thing that's got
to be fixed from within and that people
that are represented in different groups
on this committee um have all feel as
though they're giving adequate
information uh yet some people on the
committee feel that they're not and uh
also one of the outstanding things that
I heard was that uh there's not a lot of
support what they really need is uh
strategic planning and they need some
facilitation on how to work as a
committee because whether you have what
do you have 20 20 29 or you have 33 or
you have 47 once you get over 15 you've
got to have really good organization in
order for a committee to work and to be
functional and come out you know with
some really uh decent things and
evidently they did that before coid um
and now they're not so and not much has
changed other than uh they you know they
would like to do Zoom they don't get
Zoom they um have some questions about
being reimbursed about mileage um some
are some aren't they have some questions
about whether there's funds at the state
department in order for them to have
somebody come in to help them facilitate
the meetings and also do some strategic
planning answer is yes answer is no you
know back and forth so at this point I
came in with amendment that I withdrew
on the basis that I was going to offer
interim uh study for this because again
I it's something that up here we can't
solve what's broken down there and it is
a very very important committee and some
people a lot the people that I talk to
are passionate about it they they really
on either side they really want things
to work um and I think if uh a outside
study a third group study on this on
this Council uh can give some
suggestions um and if the State
Department of Education uh steps up a
little little bit in their
facilitation um I think it can work but
I think it's you talk about government
messing where it shouldn't um this is
one of those places where I think we're
just going to rearrange the deck chairs
on the Titanic and um it's still going
to be sunk so uh I think interim study
is the best way out of here represent
cordelli uh thank you um I guess i'
start off by saying um I would
respectfully disagree with the people
who may be talk to you um about the fact
that the uh uh SAC functioned well
before CO as a member of the committee
at that point I did not see that um and
secondly in terms of um us um um dealing
with the membership um and the LBA audit
um the
LBA uh audit will provide
recommendations I have no indication
that they are going to revise or
recommend revision of who the members
are of the committee I think that would
be
unusual um but uh so you know waiting
until an LBA audit comes out with some
recommendations with which possibly
might have some thoughts on Who members
should be or will they just say look at
the federal guidelines um I I cannot
support uh interal study at this point
and I will be supporting the amendment
that has been put
discussion I I do have uh did the audit
requests
specifically address this issue of
committee membership do you know
represent
b or whomever may have been there
because I do agree with represent uh
cordelli when I was on prior to
representative
cordelli I didn't really get the feeling
the good touchy feeling that this was a
functional
group um there is a meeting coming up in
December that's going to get into more
specifics about what was requested and
what will come out of it at this time I
don't have that answer for
you thank you thank you the other
question I had have shall any committee
which is appointed have a lobbyist on
it this this group has a lobbyist on
DRC no it's not on your Amendment I'm
just asking it because it was on the
original
bill and it's on the committee makeup
right now
been there for a long time I I
understand that things change
too okay so yeah represent
Hanner I think that they are not well
there's a couple of issues with the with
the the uh the two committees the two
groups that they want to uh get rid of
the piic and the D they this committee
is supposed to look at um
General what's happening in the state
not individual complaints but what are
what are Trends in the state or what are
things that the Department of Education
should look at because it's it's
happening Statewide and these are the
two groups that have that view from the
state state level now when you say
lobbyist it it's kind of like a a dirty
word that you're throwing out there we
in this committee use lobbyist quite a
bit to give us information about
different things and this is what that
person's job is is to get
information um they could send somebody
else that doesn't have an orange badge I
mean they're not like trying to get
profit off this group they're not trying
to make profit off this group or trying
to get their particular um organization
a better position because of their
position on this group so I just want to
throw that out there that the lobbyist
is not NE necessarily a dirty word to
use and and uh that they've been there
for a long time and they've offered
guidance and and help and information in
the past and and uh you know what what
do you said as um being functional uh in
the past they've given recommendations
to the Department of Education that have
then been brought here to legislative
um uh oversight on it so so um I just
wanted to pitch that in for the the
lobest part and I I appreciate what
you're saying I'll get to you a minute
represent leus but when I'm looking at
the parent information
center that's an organization which is
in statute
already if you look at 193 colon 34
you're going to see it and that
organization at that time was
established in 1981 and has a presence
in 49 States that's in our statute right
now I don't know if it's been updated
since uh that all occurred uh when I
looked it up on the web I saw
establishments in Vermont and Maine I
didn't see any establishments of that
organization in the capture but you know
and my my concern is not with parent
information center my concern is with
the other the DRC which they have
somebody that's
paid and we don't put the news Hampshire
school boards Association on a council
we don't put the superintendent
Association on a council but that group
does have an individual on this
particular
group I wouldn't mind it if there was it
was an organization which wasn't doing
that but there're actually there uh an
orange bads mean I'm lobbying for a
particular
position and they're going to be on that
group lobing for a particular position
and so it it just doesn't ring true to
me that that's what we want to have on a
parent
organization so that that's that that's
my concern right there and you know I
have nothing against the orange badges
we've used them many times over in fact
we've seen manifest education written by
that group well not this group but you
know the school boards Association I i'
I've worked with Mark Joyce and writing
a lot of stuff and the School
superintendants Association really fine
people and I'm not saying that Karen are
the persons there in in the DRC are are
not that but they are lobbyists too and
there is there's a line we got to draw
somewhere so I I I feel strongly that
we've got to modify this somehow but I'm
also concerned right now and maybe a
little bit different than my my partner
right beside me but I'm looking at six
different amendments on this bill right
now the first one came back in represent
Tanner the one I have your second uh
because in January 30th Cordelia had one
and then you had one in January 31 and
then we had another one in October 5 and
then another one on October 26 and
another one here on the 13th of
November Okay so we've had a we've
struggled with this we've struggled with
this bill and you know
um and of all the things to go to the
house floor and have a hot debate over
the structure of a committee or a
commission to me is the height the
Ridiculousness you know we we have other
issues which we got to go fight on you
know like Charter School building Aid
and mental health and all the other
things which are important for our
children not that this isn't but so I I
you know I I I I I ask us to be cautious
on this one right here and and try to
figure out what is the best path for
that so with that I'm going to call a
five minute
caucus and for us to just you know
scramble around a little bit with this
if we can and then come on
back pardon me one more thing before we
talk sure why not well I just want to
note that there was a lot of
conversation about including permission
to have a substitute and remote voting
participation without requiring an
in-person quorum to try and make
participation easier in the logistics
better and that's not in the proposed
amendment and I think that's another
topic pay attention to well refes Damon
you're absolutely correct because there
are states to allow the absent person to
appoint a substitute so you can have
your Corum that's required by Federal
Regulation so that's just another twist
story okay so we're gonna have a caucus
here tell you
A five minutes it's we don't want to
waste too much
time I was going to say amendments we're
doing a good job of
emplo
ahead now and pick it up uh we do have a
motion on the floor and that's on the
amendment uh this is the leas amendment
uh 24 4
56h is there any further discussion on
it Madam clerk will you please call the
role Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
Ford yes representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative pel yes representative
Coro yes representative Miler no
representative Cornell no representative
Tanner no representative Luna no no
representative Heath no Representative
wock no representative Hall no
Representative albone no Representative
cascaden no representative Damon no
chairman lad yes 10 is 10 Nam okay we
have motion on the floor uh HB 147 ought
to
pass any further discussion on
Clerk chair Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
Ford yes representative beler yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative Pell yes representative
couro yes representative Miler no
representative Cornell no representative
Tanner no Representative luno no
representative Heath no Representative
wock no representative Hall no
representative bon no Representative
cascaden no representative Damon no
chairman lad yes 10 y 10
y
motion further motion representative
Miler Bon I'd like to make a motion for
study is there a second second okay
motion made by representative B bony
second by representative W Woodcock to
bill
further discussion representative
Bon you want to talk about anymore um I
think I've said what needs to be said I
I really think um it's it's silly to be
changing the composition before you find
out what the legislative audit says I'm
more than willing to look at this again
in a bipartisan way and come up with
something that
works thank you further
discussion Madam
clerk Vice chairman cordelli no
Representative leus no representative
Ford no Representative beler no
representative dry no representative
McDonald no representative
Noble no representative Pell no
Representative corello no representative
Miler yes representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
Luna yes representative Ellison I'm
sorry representative he yes ran ran ran
out of sheets there
uh representative wock I then
Hall yes representative albone yes
representative cascan yes representative
Nays okay is that it on it yeah so the
Motions to the floor will be um inter
room study and ought to pass with the
amendment
right represent Lakers he'll do the
catch who Moved OTP I don't
study pardon that it was the OTP had to
be yeah OTP was me yes
yes uh your your choice was leus did you
make the second on that yes you did yeah
she did make the second yeah yeah we got
it
okay Mr chairman just a clarification
will the motion be OTP or otpa a yeah
yeah thank you yeah good
577 this is dealing with special
per
here
okay why you take the C and just
recognize me okay this is uh House Bill
577 relative to state aid for special
education pupils and I recognize
chairman lad yes I'd like to make a
motion to interim study
577 is there a
second leus is the U maker of the second
uh discussion represent lad yes uh the
issue of in special education complex
and and
needs and we need to start looking at
seriously in terms of funding the
program the way we need to do so there
are several ways and we had a bill this
previous year where we're trying to up
the are set categories of differentiated
Aid and fund according with
differentiated Aid uh the child with a
handicap that required a lot of time you
know would be funded at a different
level than a child who's in it for a
shorter time to learn how to say
R in speech especially when they're
they're younger in a group of five or
six kids trying that but then you have
also the category of special education
Aid which is a category which has come
out of small town and large town from
Republican town and Democrat towns that
the the responsibility that we have to
pay for special education due to the
idea individual disability Education
Act is such that we must provide these
Services as stated in our state law and
our especially the federal
law and we were told by the feds
initially that they were going to fund
40% of this we know now that the funding
level from the feds is probably down
close to 16% so we're really not
receiving from the federal government
what we should so it means we have to
appropriate more money that difficult
thing is that in many communities that
I've experienced in my district small
towns receiving kids which are requiring
intensive support through residential
placement and even several years back
the cost of these placements were
$250,000 now it's gone higher than that
even and for a small town to have two of
these youngsters appearing in the same
year moving into town it's plain devast
ating the small town does not have a
trust fund or some other Reserve fund
set up for this and so they have to come
up with this money somehow the way they
do it they have to go back to their
taxpayer the property payer taxpayer or
they take it from other areas of their
operating budget so to pay for Paul
they're going to you take from Mary over
here and that that is you know to me is
is wrong I can remember one day this
past year sitting in the speaker's
office the speaker saying we don't have
enough money down in what London are for
this special education what are you
going to do about it well you know you
got to pay the three and a half times
first so if it's $20,000 it's $70,000
you have to put up front first before
you're going to get the 80% paid by the
state up to 10 times this bill takes it
down to one and a half
times I'm not saying it's wrong but I'm
saying that this is a huge expense and
we don't know know and we've asked doe
on a number of times before I've
introduced legislation several years
back that took it down to two and a half
times Caitlyn couldn't provide me the
information at that time what the costs
would be and is that the answer I don't
know I don't know are we getting audits
done of these residential placement
centers are are the costs which were
being told we have to
pay accurate what are going into these
expenses I don't know we've seen kids
placed in Tennessee and getting a crummy
education by HHS and look what they're
going through they're going through hell
and so I think this whole gamut needs a
heavy heavy duty look and hopefully an
inter room study might help us do that
but I think it even needs more than that
I think it needs a healthy commission
study and I PL representative Heath for
putting a bill in this year to do just
that it's it's so important it's hurting
every community in the state
and herting kids so please support the
interim motion study
motion any further
comments yes represent Miler yeah not
not
withstanding what chair lad has said I
think it's important for this committee
to make a policy statement here uh uh
representative Heath has a bill in
that's going to provide a deep hopefully
will get past a deep study but I think
it's important for this committee to go
on record and say to basically
acknowledge what the chair has just said
and uh I don't see a a problem at this
point in time where this committee say
no you're right there needs to be more
state state support for special
education students
period and then let the commission the
commission then says oh this is where
the commi this is where the education
committee is that's an important
statement let the commission then say
take that policy statement forward and
do something with it
so I think that just to interm study
this at this point in time pending the
bills that's coming forward I think
would be a mistake uh because I think we
need to stay step forward and say now is
the time let's do something commission
go ahead and do it sponsored lab and
you Reon
Damon thank you
thank you representative Miler for
framing this in the way that you just
did I'm a co-sponsor on this bill
there's no District that wouldn't
benefit from more State funding for
special education I don't have any
illusion that us potentially approving
this OTP today is actually going to get
more special education money to
districts next year it's going to go to
finance and we can read the handwriting
on the wall but as a statement that we
as an education committee
see urgency to addressing special
education
funding I don't understand why anyone
wouldn't support this thank you Reon
cordelli thank
you but if this bill were to pass as it
is and finance says um you've you've got
your money it's in the budget you know
be happy with that what happens is that
the number of students who are eligible
for this Aid is dramatically increased
so all those students are going to get
less all those districts are going to
get less money for those students
because there are many more students and
there less and the appropriation isn't
changed so you're harming all those
appropriation further discussion
representative beler thank you Mr chair
I would just add that going back to to
our original conversation we had a long
time ago on this bill I think if we're
going to look at a sort of catastrophic
back stop for uh towns in this situation
which I think is wholly appropriate by
the way I think the way to deal with it
is not to broaden the pool of students
who qualify and keep at an 80% rate but
to narrow the range of students who
would qualify and cover the cost at a
higher rate by the state I think that
would be a more appropriate way to go
represent Damon you had your hand up or
did
you I did I'm sorry I'm trying to
understand what represent belter was
um I don't think that this brings less
money to districts I think that it is a
important further discussion on this
not seeing any Madam chair would you
r Mr chair you repeat motion please me
could you repeat the motion please the
bill 577 Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
Ford yes representative beler yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative Pell yes representative
corello yes representative Miler no
representative Cornell no representative
Tanner no Representative luno no
representative Heath no Representative
wock no representative Hall no
representative Alon no Representative
cascaden no representative Damon no and
chairman lad yes 10 y 10
Nays motion yes like to make a motion
OTP
please okay we have a motion made by
representative Tanner second by
577 representa
Tanner um as representative Damon said I
don't think there's a school a public
school in the state of New Hampshire
that uh wouldn't support this bill um
people School boards administrators
teachers uh parents and that I don't
think uh the solution
is telling parents of students who now
qualify for Disabilities that they no
longer qualify for Disabilities and and
make the number smaller so we can
support it more I think we need to step
up and fund special education and I need
think the federal government needs to
step up and fund federal education or
special
education
further
discussion not seeing any bam
clerk Vice chairman cordelli no
Representative leus no representative
Ford no Representative beler no
representative dry no representative
McDonald no representative Noble no
Representative peternell no
Representative corello no representative
Miler yes representative Cornell yes
representative tenner yes representative
luno yes representative Heath yes
representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes representative
albone yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon 10
yeses representative I'm sorry chairman
lad
no I was like how
10 okay
soad get the reporton me you get the
report I'll do the report and who's
okay all righty that takes here
classify more urgent cases of
special I put a feel on that just last
year categorizing at different levels
and they was rejected Finance I got to
go
there experience in this sort of thing
how do you how do you structure school
system so don't do a pile on when the
door opens justly I is it by limiting
how
get well I think I think you know just
like I always say that the schools are
under
all
the unfunded land I mean I totally agree
with all that and so you have this build
school I mean when you look at back at
you look at the money that the
government our school taxes went
down simply because they had
discretionary money to meets that built
up for a long period of time whether it
was building needs or whether it was
special paying off special ed costs or
whatever I've been working with my wife
doing a lot of the stuff going around
this St so I'm getting more and more
familiar with different schools on
finding that
super very
super in the state and some of I mean
because it's a
job
really
do by my recollection we still have to
do
151 yeah
151 437 439
651 and 627 how many is that 1 two 3 4
nine and we had
middle okay we're going to start at my
top and work our way down here so looks
like the next one up would
be
yet
okay 27 267 that's you representative
motion uh thank you I would like to move
to
pass SAR second 267 ought to pass right
here represent
vure and I have I have an amendment to
offer okay so let's let's get yeah so
representative for the uh represent cour
uh Cordell Representative cordelli makes
the motion not to pass second by
representative beler representative
cordelli um passing out uh amendments
this is the amendment that we mentioned
this morning but did not have copies um
this is U Amendment 2317 H uh from
representative
Alexander do you like to yes and this
would be uh ought to pass on Amendment
2317 okay so rep and Cordell reckman OTP
a or a on this uh Amendment
it
represent Corell you want to speak to
your motion thank you uh yes um uh I
think with the original bill um we had a
long discussion about that and uh a
number of people saw issues with the
original language uh so uh this uh
Amendment hopefully clarifies the
language and you see the new language on
Line's 20 through
26 um uh this was arrived at um between
the uh um the sponsor of the amendment
and the Department of
Education um basically um it says that
uh the
superintendent of a school or the chief
executive officer uh can
um try and um work with the uh unions to
uh open up for additional criminal
background checks on a recurring basis
um after the initial employment
background check and I think that's uh
the key that um we have many people um
in the field who um have not had
background checks um for years because
of um the uh their length of service and
when um additional background check
language has been added to the statutes
over the past few years um so I think
that this um plugs a hole in the process
to um um we had discussion earlier today
about background checks and the
importance well I think this plugs a
whole in public school background
checks as the the second the catch
wordss for me which uh I support on line
the last word in line
21 superintendent May negotiate so this
is up to the individual superintendent
and that receiving Association to decide
whether they're going to go this
thing represent
M yeah I don't think this language is
necessary this came from uh one
particular School District uh this is
permissible language anyway currently in
in collective bargaining and if if a
superintendent wanted to pursue this
they could put this on the table uh and
I just don't I don't think this is
necessary we typically in this committee
do not take something that's from one
particular individual uh he cited a
concern that he had and he could be able
and he can put this on the table at any
time when they negotiate this language
is not necessary at this point in time
further
discussion okay
represent Celli yes just to follow up on
that um I did follow up with that
superintendent um recently um and uh he
did try and put it on the table with the
Union but was told uh there's nothing in
statute um about doing something like
that so I think that's why we need to
put this in
statute report for that yes um if you've
been involved in collective bargaining
as I have there's always anything can be
put on the table as long as both parties
have something to give or something to
take so obviously in that this the
situation you're in there was nothing to
give on the part of the administration
wanted further discussion representative
Tanner and then representa
Heath just um because this is a contract
negotiation uh that that covers this
there are a lot of people that work in
schools that are employed who are not
under the contract and therefore um it
really is picking out a specific group
of people and and putting onus on
them represent Heath quick question how
would you keep this from becoming
capricious is there somebody wants to
can you repeat the question please how
would you prevent this bill from
becoming arbitrary or capricious um for
example if there was a dispute between a
teacher and an administrator um that
they could use this um kind of as a
vehicle because I don't like you I'm
again
anybody yes represent belon yes I think
I can answer that with with the fact
that because this is enabling
legislation that enables collective
bargaining on this basis that would be
the issue of the collective bargaining
agreement and I couldn't possibly see a
uh Union being um lacking the foresight
to not craft this negotiation and policy
in such a way as to prohibit the
individual targeting of teachers based
further
discussion not see your hands uh the
motion on the table is to approve the
amendment
2317 and HB
267 not seeing any further discussion
Madam
clerk Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
Ford yes representative beler yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative Pell yes representative
Corella yes representative Miler no
representative Cornell no representative
Tanner no representative Luna no
representative Heath no Representative
wock no representative Hall no
Representative bbon no Representative
cascaden no representative Damon no
10 okay we have a motion on the table
OTP on HB
discussion no yes represent Tanner oh
we're not we have voted on
the right yeah yeah we're just going on
the OTP
now okay Madam
clerk VI chairman cordelli yes
representative
leus yes representative Ford yes yes
representative beler yes representative
dry yes representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
Pell yes representative Corell yes
representative Miler no representative
Cornell no representative Tanner no
Representative luno no representative
Heath Representative wock no
representative Hall no representative
bon no Representative cascaden no
representative Damon no uh chairman lad
yes 10 10 motion further
motions second wait a minute represent
McDonald thank you Mr chair I move that
this be placed in intern
study is there a
Luz represent
McDonald I believe the discussions that
we are having are good and need to
continue and that the only way for that
to be possible is to have further work
on this bill so thank
you
okay further
discussion Madam clerk the motion is
interim study on the bill
267 Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative laus yes representative
Ford yes representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative Pell yes representative
Cora yes representative Miler no
representative Cornell no representative
Tanner no representative Luna no
representative Heath no Representative
wock no representative Hall no
representative bon no representative cat
scen no representative Damon no chairman
yes 10 y 10
n
yes second okay we have a motion made by
represent Miler uh to itl Second by
okay represent
Miler okay represent
discussion mam cler VI Vice chairman
cordelli
no Representative leus no representative
Ford no representative Belcher no
representative shy no representative
McDonald no representative Noble no
representative p
no representative Corell no
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative Luna yes representative
Heath representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes representative
bbon yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad no
days represent Hall is doing the article
report the
report and who's doing the other one
otpa I guess
me all
right okay going down this list that
I've
schools
study okay second okay we have a motion
made by represent Noble waren p uh
505 this is a bill dealing with
Comprehensive Mental Health and schools
uh represent Noble Rec uh made a motion
for interim study second by
representative cordelli representative
Noble thank you Mr
chair so I went back and watched a lot
of our we had a lot of work sessions on
mental health and I watch some of the
hearings and it's clear we have a
significant issue with mental health and
Behavioral Health in our
schools in our June um work session
representative luno um asked what I
think are two very important
questions um one is what are the factors
that contribute to this EP epidemic and
is this partially an epidemic of our
making so I think for the sake of
students and teachers um we need to have
a better understanding of what's going
on in our schools and and see if we can
do something to help a devate the
problem so you know we're talking about
the mental health of children here so we
need to tread
lightly and I I don't think we should
make any changes to mental health
curriculum or anything having to do with
mental health until we have some answers
problem thank you uh represent Celli uh
thank you um yes you know it's one thing
to teach someone about mental health but
let's let's find the causes and trying
to address the causes of the problems um
that students are seeing clearly
bullying is one of them anxiety
depression um and we'll be talking about
some of the causes of anxiety and
depression in a few minutes but um two
weeks ago I even found an a study study
claims humans having sex with a extinct
species 60,000 years ago could be why
you suffer from mental issues so um I'm
not sure if we know the causes but I
think that with interim study we
certainly can start to address some of
the ones that are known and try and
resolve um those issues for our students
rather than teaching them um about um
mental
EXC okay no further discussion the chair
can we get the source of that
study
yep um it was uh in the Daily Mail on no
you
nope okay further
discussion M yes representative Balon uh
thank you chairman lad um I I thought
what I recall that uh representative
Damon was asked to just uh change that
confused re Damon thank you and thank
you representative Boni um so I hadn't
spoken to the motion for interim study
but there is an amendment that everyone
should have that simply remove the word
comprehensive from the three places that
occurs in the bill I'm sorry and all
this paperwork I can't find my copy so I
can't tell you the amendment number does
somebody have it it is uh 2316 2361
right which used to be my phone number
um um this
isn't so OS didn't
send this is not the correct Amendment
this is someone else's amendment that
they've attributed to
me sorry I didn't look at it carefully
this morning when I picked it
up um
so I don't I apologize I don't know how
to proceed because this is
not I don't think this
is
yeah right now this this motion this
interim study because it said
comprehens yeah so we should go to that
later
so relative to interim
study there is a overwhelming abundance
of knowledge about causes of of the
increase in mental health conditions in
people of all ages and most especially
students it's it's not unknown or hard
to find I don't think
delaying putting mental health education
into
curriculum to study that causes more
accomplishes
anything further
discussion not seeing any Madam clerk
please call the
RO thanks chman cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
Ford yes representative beler yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative Pell yes representative
corello yes representative Miler no
representative Cornell no representative
Tanner no Representative luno no
representative Heath no Representative
wock no representative Hall no
representative bon no Representative
cascaden no representative Damon no
chairman lad yes 10 10 days further
motions repr
Damon I'm not sure on the process but
can I now bring this amendment forward
which I misspoke a minute ago this is
language you got you got you can't bring
on Amendment for without having a motion
on the floor I speak
is there a second second okay we have
motion made by represented Damon second
505 okay can I now speak yes you can
speak you know you can you recognize to
speak to the motion that's on the floor
and if you during that speech if you
want to bring introduce your me you may
do
so thank you for helping me with the
process
so I am in support of this bill um I
think it is a very
important
part of how we should be educating
people to thrive that they understand
basic aspects of mental
health the amendment that I've proposed
to 361 simply removes the word
comprehensive from the three places that
it had occurred in the bill in the title
and in the text so it is
not as uncertain we had a lot of
discussion about what does comprehensive
mean we don't Define everything else
that specifically so that Amendment just
makes it a little bit more at the
discretion of the Local District as we
control okay do you want to speak to the
um
amendment now yes represent
leus aren't we doing this
already pardon me aren't we doing this
already I mean we even have the health
education curriculum guidelines and
everything I'm still not sure why we
need to put it in when we're doing
it I wasn't on that subcommittee
sorry I've been involved with that
subcommittee and I recognize we do have
mental health issues in our school and
it's uh an issue that's
Statewide um I've been an advocate for
putting mental health into this however
where I am right
now is
that we do have it in our Ed 306
rules we do have it in our Frameworks
which addresses Mental
Health we do know that within 193e that
we do have the substantive criteria for
an adequate education which health and
wellness are that and we also have
within that same area statute that
nothing can be changed by
rule unless it's gone through to change
those subst criteria areas unless it's
done by the general
court we also have in 193 J and two
which deals with suicide
prevention but also mental health as
says um Training School faculty and
staff including contracted personnel and
designated School volunteers and youth
suicide risk fa factors warnings Etc and
it goes on and says educating students
the importance of safe and healthy
choices and coping strategies
recognizing risk factors and warning
signs of mental
disorders and suicide in it in oneself
and others and writing helpy seeking
strategies for oneself or others
including how to engage School resources
and refer friends for help we've done
this through
mtssb we have a program with three steps
in the schools that exists right
now and I'm not going through the three
steps I think we all know them you know
the classroom teacher teacher at risks
and then those and those really engaging
in intervention it's the third
step with this process going on I've
thought a lot about this and I'm trying
to find out where is this red line
between behaviors which are totally
unacceptable maybe more behavioral like
I said
behaviors and where does mental health
start and what has pushed me the other
way is what I had a discussion with my
daughter who is a life skills teacher at
a middle
school and a student put his fist right
through the sheetrock in the wall and
started screaming and yelling and having
heck of a time he of course had to be
removed but to remove from a classroom
it takes how much time good five minutes
10 minutes disruption of time this is
what's happening in schools and when you
take the amount of time that's these
disruptions
occurring you have lost probably as much
as 10% to even more 20% % of
instructional time in a given year it's
lost and we ask why are we not doing
well in school well obviously you know
the instructional time's been cut back
but taking the story a little farther
what happened is the student was
removed and my daughter whose teacher
suggest we need just get hold of mom and
dad or parent and have the kid taken
home parent came first thing the parent
says get in the car I'll take you to
Dunkin
Donuts well that's just not that's going
to reinforce negative
behaviors then when it was stated out
loud that we need because the child is
now fighting really hard we need to call
the police child settled down and got
into the car next day that child's back
in the
classroom uh it comes to a point where
is behavior separated from mental health
where is that red line where is the
difference I'm not an expert on it I
know reps and cascaden you've dealt with
this with your programs as a
superintendent as a individual working
in the schools and I know a lot of
schools have these programs I won't
mention that that the program this
school has in place but they have this
program in place and several other
programs the behaviors
continue are these behaviors behaviors
or are they mental health
disorders I I see other health
impairment that's one of our criteria
for IEPs 13 one of 13 that's increasing
in
numbers so I guess that I'm I'm a little
bit confused as to is this something
that's an environmental issue coming in
from the home a behavior that coming off
the streets or a behavior it's a
resultant of kids being attacked on the
internet with anxiety and sexually
driven materials they're coming to
school they're not interested in what's
academic they can't they're on this
other task so I I think that this issue
is much larger than what we know here in
this group right here and it really does
needs a whole lot of study and and a
proper re answer on it and unfortunately
it's I think it's
societal and you know I'm not giving up
on it but I do believe that
um you know it's it's uh just by putting
it into statute say well now we got
mental health there we're going to
resolve it I don't think we've already
been dealing with it and so we need to
take more action just putting more
you further
discussion represent penell yes thank
you um I justess my biggest concern with
this legislation although we all are
aware that mental health is a
significant concern is that mental
health is included in the definition of
health education so I find this
redundant
yep that's something I alluded to that
we have it in the Frameworks we have it
in Ed
306 and we have it spoken in other areas
of legislation as well and it is part of
Health and
Wellness so you know the thing we start
walking down the road and i' G give it a
lot of thought do we take all the
subtopics of Science and write them
under science do we take all the
subtopics of history and write those
down and start just cataloging our our
legislation
statutes uh or or is this something that
we're getting into we're micromanaging
and should we be putting this elsewhere
you know like in the rules and letting
the locals deal with these
issues they're the ones have to deal
they're the
teachers further discussion would it be
a good uh idea Mr
chairman to consider funding research in
the universities on exactly the
subject offering it basically a grant
for research by the various colleges or
schools of Education into the behaviors
we're now seeing exhibited in the
schools as to their causes possible
responses etc etc well represent Ford I
could respond to that and probably not
in very positive terms um on the teacher
shortage committee we had teachers that
are new teachers to this State new
teachers to profession and what did they
tell us and represent my you're a part
of that I don't think I was properly
prepared for what I'm walking into in my
preparation
courses you know I I had a lot of the
content and some of that but I walked in
and and what I'm encountering is
something I was never prepared
for and to deal with that is is an issue
so I you know I think that you know a
lot of your college professors are
sitting there in their in their their
classrooms and they're not experiencing
the reality of what we're encountering
and it's just it's an awful situation so
I don't put a lot of Hope in the in the
post-se secary system to fix this I wish
they
would I respond mean I don't know if
that's gerain to you know the motion on
the
floor well it's we're we're on this
topic of mental health and you know I
guess we could could go forever on it so
uh let's I I apologize for getting in
the post of responding even to that
question so but um let's represent
Damon thank you Mr chair just two
remarks I don't think relying on the
fact that this is in the 306 rules
currently is a comfortable certainty for
me certainly that that would continue to
be the case given the DraStic revisions
that are proposed and that have been
largely not very transparent
so I don't trust to rely on that and I
would like to remind people of the
testimony that we heard from multiple
young people last
winter really amazingly articulate
wonderful teens saying this is not
happening in the schools now and it
should be if you remember the young
woman who is now a freshman at Welsley
actually I don't recall if she was the
person driving or if her friend was
driving but her friend had a panic
attack while they were in the car and
neither one of them knew what it was
fortunately this young woman had the
wherewithal to look it up and figure it
out and help her friend to
safety we should be educating people to
know what that looks like and
how to First Aid it it's not treatment
it's just safety for now it's not
happening
enough well I I just want to clarify one
thing that was said that we've been told
that that's not going to happen is that
we were told by the Department of
Education right here that they cannot
touch those substantive criteria areas
those key elements that are under 193e
by changing the rules the rules and
those components are not going to change
that came from Dr Green right here when
he was testifying before us we asked him
that question he said we are not going
to be changing those areas in the e Ed
redrafting so that that was spoken to us
so uh I I think that that's you know I
to say that Doe is going to change
something or the state board's going
they're not going to do that they've
said they will not they cannot by
Statute do
it further discussion represent Hall
thank you Mr chair um this language as
is seems to me could have the power of
having an extremely powerful impact on
kids I'm not seeing the downside of it
other than oh it might be written
somewhere
else you know if somebody could you know
I've heard a lot of testim a lot of
conversation here but I'm not hearing
really what is wrong with it other than
I you know is a how it affects
kids further qu further discussion Madam
clerk Amendment yeah this this on the
amendment Vice chairman cordelli
no Representative leus no no
representative Ford
no Representative beler no
representative dry no representative
McDonald no representative Noble no
representative Pell no representative
cello no representative Miler yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
luno yes representative Heath yes
representative yes representative
Hall yes representative bbon yes
representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad
no 10 y 10
n represent
Bel uh Mr chair would it be an
appropriate time for me to um introduce
Amendment
2374 pardon me would it be an
appropriate time now for me to introduce
Amendment
2374 I
thought
well we we have a motion that ought to
pass in the floor right now and yes this
would be an appropriate time for you to
put Amendment forward represent Bel
thank you Mr chair um I would like to
introduce this amendment 2374 H um I I
legitimately spent a good deal of time
um trying to figure out where we might
agree where we might disagree and where
we might find a center
ground we I think we had a copy we're
we're all looking for those represent
Bel I think you provided me yeah they
should have come around earlier uh is it
good you don't you don't have them
um we didn't get it over who has not got
it I don't think anybody so it stopped
somewhere
okay anyway I'll without getting into
the details of it I'll keep talking hold
sure we they I think they should have
[Music]
there excellent so I I tried to think
real hard about where we might agree and
where we might disagree on this and I
think we can all agree that there that
there is an issue that we would like to
address and I think the concerns that
many of us had have really mostly boil
down to a concern that that there could
be a line crossed where we're going from
um information and providing students
with information you know tools for
their toolbox to moving and
transitioning to the um administration
of healthcare at a classroom which would
be um something that could really be
more harmful than
helpful um so I've I've pulled
information and and language from the
National Institutes of Health that help
me to Define what constitutes the
practice of psychology and I I change
the language from instead of mental
health to psychological conditions and
stress disorders not because there's any
significant meaningful difference
between those two bits of language but I
feel like psychological conditions and
stress disorders is a little bit more a
little bit more tangible a little bit
less nebulous um it would allow and I
and I know some people have really
wanted to put this in the law so this
this would do that they would allow for
the the overview as Official Guidelines
of psychological conditions and stress
disorders without without the putting
those guard rails up so we make sure we
don't get into the practice where
teachers are beginning to do things
where they were recommending treatments
and procedures and practices that would
um that would constitute the practice of
mental health care that would create a
potential problem for students because
they're not in an environment where
that's where they're ready for that in a
classroom perhaps in a guidance
counselor's office but not in a
classroom we're putting we don't want to
put that on teachers where they're in a
situation where they could even have
liability for recommending treatments
and whatnot um so I I really think this
could walk the line as a as a compromise
um position thank you need a second yeah
was was there a second on the I don't
think so okay so there we have a second
representative
Woodcock thank you chairman Le um v i I
have I understand the the um and
appreciate the fact that you try to keep
this B Alive this however I have when
the two the spiritual peace doesn't
bother me at all but uh omitting that
what what does bother me is treatment
and wellness practices for instance
common common Wellness practices like
breathing or exercise ing bad diet
walking outside to help with stress or
or or uh other types of issues uh you
may consider those treatment some keep
Wellness practices when you take those
opportunities for reasonable simple age
appropriate Solutions out of the options
of the teachers toolbox then we're not
really giving them in these these
students anything creditable that they
can use when they have the opportunity
right there it's like you're you're
you're prepping them not showing them
how to go to the next step so I I just I
I find that um and I think this you're
intense fine M but I just those two
things to take those two critical Parts
out of this piece I think it just Waters
it down to make it valueless uh in my
point because I think those treatments
and wellness practices without being
without even thinking about being a
doctor lawyer Indian chief we're just
talking about typical stuff that can be
used in in this case thank you Mr chair
yes representative beler
thank you just to offer a quick response
on that from the National Institutes of
Health Website uh under elements of
psychotherapy um it says applying
mindfulness and relaxation techniques
such as meditation and breathing
exercises so I think the the real the
real thing that we're looking at here is
and the difference between a PR the
practicing of medicine versus just
normal human interactions is is a is a
teacher acting on her own or his her own
accord to
to tell a student you know hey take a
breath you know count to 10 and then
respond and and just things like that
which are normal parts of Human
Relationships and interactions or is it
are we codifying in law and in and in uh
procedures that we're going to be
administering these things to the class
because I think that's when we start
Crossing that line into Healthcare and
and I think that's backed up by this
definition on on the NIH page
one more yes go ahead I think this
committee and this legislature over the
last year has put teachers in such a
honest position and fightful what they
can say and cannot say in the classroom
when we just talk about something as
simple as breathing relax take a step
back some teachers going be afraid to
say that could now someone may interpret
as you did that you could be predicting
or or or or or prescribing activities we
have not made it easy for teachers to me
we made it a horrible profession people
to get into you wonder there's the
shortage they aren't prepared and what
we give them their hands are cuffed we
just can't keep on doing this and expect
kids to grow and be and well and coming
and teachers to come into the business
it's just it's just not a well it's not
a good thing to do in my mind further
discussion yes representative Tanner
thank you um I'd just like to follow on
representative woodcox uh because the
minute that you presented this and I'm
looking at it in Wellness practice and
treatments I'm thinking of the health
class that I had where we did stress
reduction and we talked about deep
breathing exercises and we did we
practiced a couple of those and about
coaching where I had kids that were
particularly anxious about being in a
game or if there was a big crowd or if
we were going to the championship about
counting to 10 about going through a
certain um type of of procedure when
they're at the foul line you know to
bounce twice to take a deep breath to
look at the basket before they shoot so
that they block out a lot of things uh
positive visualization before you go
into a test or you're you're in a game
uh or you're going down a slom course
just closing your eyes and going down
through the solom course and seeing you
come out the other end and as a winner
um and I can't tell I actually um had
just probably a year ago a young man
come up to me and now I haven't taught
since two 2004 and he said that the only
reason he made it through basic training
was because he did the breathing
exercises that he learned in health
class so I totally agree with uh
representative Woodcock that you're just
people are going to read this this is
just like all the other divisive concept
thing and it's going to change it's
going to it it changes the whole dynamic
between a teacher and a student between
a coach and a player um between an adult
and a trusted adult and a kid that is
really experiencing panic attack or
anxiety or just needs one or two little
cues so that they can make it through
that high stakes testing that they're
doing or or the you know the the fou
shot that they have to make so there's
no way I could could uh support this
discussion
okay
umef caucus yeah we will we'll have a
brief caucus on
o'clock
second
forward here we still have number bills
uh I'd like to recognize uh represent
beler thank you Mr chair uh at this time
I will withdraw Amendment
2374 and who made the second I did would
you withdraw your second I withdraw my
second thank
you so that takes us back to where we
were we were we had a bill which was uh
ought to pass with uh
another am Amendment and everything was
101 so I think we need an off to pass we
need to V amend as amended that's where
go so is there going to be a motion put
forward over there there is a motion
Damon Miler OT
already right okay and and the amendment
okay okay so what we have to do now is
just uh V on the whole okay so it's
ought to pass as amended with am to pass
just to pass okay
okay okay so that's what you want to go
forward with ought to pass
okay
yes uh let me just do this one vote I'll
let you know okay okay we have a motion
to OTP on 505
further discussion Madam
cordelli the motion is ought to pass yes
no Representative leus no representative
Ford no Representative beler no
representative dry no representative
McDonald no representative Noble no
representative Pell no Representative
corello no representative Meer yes
represent representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
Luna yes representative Heath yes
representative wock yes representative
Hall yes representative Bon yes
representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad no
10 y 10 Nays
okay chairman lad we go forward I got a
procedural question we have one of our
members of our cers that like to change
their
267 representative
McDonald uh brought forth a motion to
income
study and one of our members was change
their and go back and do that well we
could you could we could entertain a
motion to reconsider yes that can be
done right now because we're still in
possession of the bill okay would move
to reconsider it because it was a 101
vote right yes a 101 so I would move to
reconsider so one of our members could
change their vote to support the interim
study okay uh first before we get there
I I have another question for the whole
committee here we have few bills left
and we're holding up OS they can't go
home until we go home are we
going poor people so what what we have
to do is we have to let Jen know are
there going to be any more amendments
coming out any changes to anything or
are we just going with what we got and
we're going to clean it up today I know
across the hallway sometimes they've
gone to 5:00 5:30 but they let OS go
home I think what we've got is what
home so we have a so my motion is to
reconsider uh reconsider House Bill 267
is there a
second second okay so we have a motion
made by represent Miler
and this one's still on the table well
the motion is just for
reconsideration then we'll have a vote
after this to revote that but we have to
have a motion to reconsider so the
motion was made by represent Miler and
cordelli yes we we finished with
505 the the two motions will be ought to
pass and study
yeah so we have a motion on the table
for reconsideration 267 made by Miler
second by uh
cordelli all those in favor of
reconsideration put your hands up okay
we we got
reconsideration now um now I'd like to
reconsider the interim
study interim study motion by
representative
mcon
second I'll
motion
what what what are we okay what we need
to do is we need to what motion we
looking at there was a
original in room
study on that right yeah the original
motion was ought to pass as amended um
was 1010 then we moved to inter room
study okay so consider so okay so to
want to reconsider the interim study
what what do a roll yeah yeah
interesting
okay
call okay so we'll have a roll call on
267 on the the
motion Myer and was second by
you Valerie Oh by Valerie okay getting
late okay yes represent McDonald thank
you for the
correction okay Madam clerk would you
please callor
cordelli yes representative leus yes
representative Ford yes representative
Belcher yes representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
pel yes representative corello yes
representative miler no representative
Cornell no representative Tanner no
representative luno
yes representative Heath no
representative Woodcock
yes representative
Hall
no Representative bbon
no Representative cascaden no
representative Damon
y so the motion to study
right and we did we take did we take an
itl vot that we did we did yeah it was
10 was 10 also so we'll still do it oh
no
that's minity report against the stud no
no there will not be and you'll write
the report okay so you got that
everybody so it's a
137 there for inter room
Report are we beond that
okay see I drink more of this morning's
awake than okay all righty uh we did 505
yet okay I'll make this but why don't
you okay this
I can
yeah all right yes this is 151 relative
to mental health education um chairman
lad do you have a motion on that yes I
itl and is there a
second I'll
second representative Noble thank you uh
comments from the chair yes I I just
keep it very brief I am not supportive
of doing
anything where we are touching 193e
adequacy and this would put mental
health into adequacy and if anything it
belonged in studies not here in adequacy
bill represent Noble anything nothing
further any other comments from anybody
on the
bill seen none sure
okay yeah yeah I mean this is just
comment and then we're probably going to
vote yeah right yeah so so thanks very
much U Mr chair so Senate Bill 151 has
obviously passed the Senate and um and
it's a it's a very important bill I
think the Senate um in a bipartisan
fashion recognize the importance of
including mental health studies in the
um in the the um minimum standards for
um uh for
um uh courses and subjects that uh that
have to be offered in all public schools
so um uh so I would support report what
the uh what the Senate has done sent to
us so that we can move this on to the
governor's office thank
you further comment from anybody if not
Madam clerk to
you Vice chairman
cordelli
yes representative
leus yes representative
Ford yes representative beler yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative peternell yes
representative corello yes
representative Miler no representative
Cornell no representative Tanner no
representative Luna
no representative Heath Representative
wock no representative Hall no
representative bon no Representative
cascaden no representative Damon no
chairman lad
yes ten ten further
motions I'll move on to
pass motion made by represent second by
go Vice chairman
cordelli no Representative leus no
representative Ford no representative
Belcher no representative dry no
representative McDonald no
representative Noble no representative
Pell no Representative corello no
representative
Miler yes representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
Luna yes representative Heath
representative wock yes representative
Hall yes representative Boni yes
representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad no
report okay marching
down have we done 623 yet no we no we we
uh 218
218 218 professional
development8
okay
[Music]
motion thank you Miss thank you Mr chair
I would like to move in expedient to
it B thank you Mr chair so I think the
issues that um surround this bill are
several um there is no appropriation of
funds for the grant that it sets up um I
do not recall any statistics being uh
presented justifying the
expenditure there are many other options
current ly being looked at and
entertained both by this committee and
others as far as um uh grants and other
things teachers for hiring and
retaining um and also local options to
already and I I'll you know say we we
dealt with other bills today uh that are
dealing with this issue similar type
issues and so uh I I agree with what uh
representative belter just said so I
cannot support the bill
either represent cordelli thank you I
believe the uh fiscal note indicates
that the uh
um the department would
require uh half a million dollars a year
for the program yep and uh a new
Madam clerk would you please call the
role CH chairman cordelli
yes representative leus yes
representative
Ford yes representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative Pell yes representative
corello yes representative
Miler no no
representative Cornell no representative
Tanner no representative Luna no
representative Heath no representative
Woodcock no representative Hall no
representative bon no representative
cascaden uh no representative Damon no
OTP represent Miler moves OTP yes sir a
second paron me cascad
second I'm sorry who did second
represent
cascaden
begrudgingly representative uh luno or
Miler whoever made it getting late do
you want to discuss it no move ref
cascaden no you're
good call The rooll Madam
clerk Vice chairman cordelli
no Representative leus no representative
Ford no Representative beler no
representative dry no representative
McDonald no representative Noble no
representative
Pell no Representative corello no
representative miler yes representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative luno yes representative
Heath representative wock yes
representative Hall yes representative
alone yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad no
days
really
okay next one down on my list is 437 I
believe reading assessment Intervention
Program
it am coming around
yep Jen did you order the
yet your
choice
you want to do it okay representative
Cordell you recognize for a motion thank
you I would like to move on to pass is
there a second
represent
laus uh so representative cordelli
recommends OTP second by represent leus
representa Cordell you
recognized yes I would like to
U offer uh
Amendment uh
H
okay
if I could speak to my motion go ahead
yeah
um uh thank you um we've had a lot of
discussion about this bill um
unfortunately uh several sections were
uh ruled non gerain today so they will
be brought up next year but few points I
wanted to make um the science of reading
is a body of research that's been done
over the past several decades including
research on how the brain works um it is
not an ideology a philosophy a political
cartel we in this bill there are several
important um aspects to it um
proficiency at the third grade we know
what what that looks like here in the
state um and it's been said that from
kindergarten through the third grade
children are learning to read beginning
in the fourth grade they're reading to
learn so what are we doing to them if at
the end of the third grade they can't
read that impacts their
future um we talked about mental illness
uh just a little while ago
um don't you think if a
child cannot read is struggling to read
in the third or fourth grade or later
that they might have anxiety and
depression to Hallmarks of mental
illness here's here's an article from
Neuroscience decom poor literacy link to
worst mental health worst mental health
worldwide
incarceration onethird of Dyslexia
students become so frustrated in school
they give up and leave high school
without
graduating 85% of children in juvenile
detention are
illiterate one and four children grew up
not knowing how to read
and um I believe it's 75 80% of PE
adults in prison are
illiterate we have
statistics our proficiency scores by
least other
states have moved forward
with um the science of reading and
evidence-based research
as of
July per education week 32 states have
passed legislation on evidence-based
science of reading
research
and education week identified six
categories of primary need in the
legislation uh teacher prep teacher
certification renewal assessment
materials
intervention only 12 of those 32 have
even five or six of those categories we
would be
one if the original Bill had passed or
the original
Amendment uh this follows on to doe
initiatives um just recently I was
reading about um a July um initiative
micro credentials are now available for
educators in the science of
credentials letters training we've
talked about over
3,000 teachers and parents and
grandparents have been trained um in the
science of reading and uh evidence-based
research
um but what happens to those teachers
who go through this extensive and it's
extensive training but then walk back
into the class room where they're doing
using instructional materials based on
balance of literacy which is contrary to
everything that they've learned what are
we we're wasting their time we're
time
um I've worked on this
legislation with local people I've been
to professional development sessions
in londondary I've been to two or three
seminars um around the state um with
Educators um related to uh this uh
legislation um I've had a national and
international conversations with
Educators reviewing this
legislation um one of whom um is an
international expert was the co-author
of letter program has worked extensively
with this and I was in conversation with
with her last
criticisms kids learn differently well
right but according to research
95% of students who learn learn using
this type of instruction can learn to
read
what do we and when you compare that to
our current literacy rates doesn't that
that speak volumes about the direction
we need to go um you know unfortunately
sections that I'll bring back next year
are critical critical sections teacher
prep
programs H what are we doing when we've
got and um the uh National Quality
teacher
um Council raid did a survey and rid
colleges three colleges in New Hampshire
including you got a D or an F in their
teacher prep programs using this
research that has been done over
decades
um in terms of waiting let's wait let's
wait let's wait but the screening call
for in this Pro in this program um in
this bill doesn't start until January
2025 but in the meantime we can get
started getting reports from the
Department of Education
um advancing with uh parental
involvement and and instruction uh
identifying instructional materials by
the Department of Education which is all
called for in this
bill and if we wait what are we doing to
those first and second graders who might
be struggling to read right now we're
sentencing them to another 2 years of
inability to read
properly
um you know it's easy to do nothing it's
easy but sometimes it takes courage to
do
something thank you thank you further
leus when we talked about about this in
interim
study
um R cascaden who has been who has
instituted this in her area already said
that everybody should already be doing
this everybody should already be doing
this and the problem is they're not they
don't all have such good leadership and
they they are not all doing this so this
is to try to make sure everybody is
doing
this if I could go ahead yeah um we've
had several letters from teachers in
conquered talking about the fact that
they don't do this there um I've been
working with a specialed reading
specialist who just
transferred out of her District to a new
District because she was tired of
banging her head against the wall for 3
years trying to get them to move in this
direction and in her old District so she
switched districts to a district that
was doing
this further
discussion yes represent Tanner and then
represent luno thank you um I think last
year when we had the or last part of
this year when we had the dyslexia bill
that is now gone through here and been
signed by the governor and now in law
where students are now tested three
times a year between first and third
fourth grade and if there's a
dyslexia uh possibility immediate
intervention happens and I've heard from
a couple of people that it's really made
a difference in in uh what's happening
in first through third grade but I agree
that some of this material needs to also
be pushed thank you yes um I think
actually in 377 which is in law now it's
only twice a year is required for
screening that they already had to do
well yeah the same would apply here but
there are three required um and uh
dislexia is maybe 15% of the students
what about all the rest because we're
not addressing them in
377 but we are addressing them here
let's take care of those students also
re
luno thank you Mr chair so you know I've
never been a professional educator and I
know there's a lot of of um former
profession professional Educators around
this table but um reading's always been
important to my family um uh my mom and
dad owned Gibson's bookstore here in
conquer in the 60s and 70s um my mom was
a librarian in hopkington for a decade
followed by 15 years as the reference
librarian here in conquer she also had a
career as a public school teacher both
in sandwich and in hopkington uh so
reading is very important to me and I
understand it certainly from being on
the school board that you um you learn
to read and then read to learn and and
uh uh and that's it that reading is a
critical instructional tool and um and
uh important for all students but I'll
tell you I don't have to get very far
into this bill um before I run into a
wall of words
that I just can't support um in the
current under the current climate the
first set is on page 11 the department
of educ on page 11 line 11
the Department of Education shall
identify and
contract um I've seen the results of
when they identifying contract and the
results have not been good and um down
on page
29 um all public school on page 20 line
29 all public schools and Charter Public
Schools shall screen all students in
kindergarten use through grade three
using the universal screen reader
approved by the department again um uh
no no real standards there for whatever
they're approving and Contracting with
and I think a lot of questions um that
Grant Staters would have about the
Judgment that comes um uh from the
commissioner and the state board so um
so I I I I like the the the idea I
certainly think we heard uh a lot of
comments during the um during the public
hearing and during work set several work
sessions on this bill with with regards
to the efficacy of of the um of the
instructional practices that that that
this bill uh promotes but also the
importance to not rule out other
instructional practices or or curriculum
that are necessary to be part of the
toolkit so I I really I can't support a
u an a to pass on this it's not because
I don't have courage it's not because I
don't like reading uh it's not uh you
know because I don't have an experience
I don't have experience as a as an
educator but uh do have experience as
being a legislator and on school boards
that uh that that the language used in
this bill under the current climate uh
is just unworkable and um uh but I would
support a um you know interim study type
motion for this thank
you further discussion represent
leus this sounds to me like another
attack on the doe um
um the doe is supposed to be making this
screener available to districts at no
cost so why they would not identify it
and figure out which one they're going
to make available at no cost I don't
know it sounds not like we
should it just sounds like another
attack on the doe that's
all representative
cascaden I I think think that we would
not disagree on the fact that reading is
one of the most fundamental skills we
need to teach all
kids I think that this is government
overreach in the sense that curriculum
and instruction is local
control there's Pro there's a name of a
program in here or there was I mean you
mentioned letters okay so that's a
commercial
program but a district may find
something from another vendor that meets
the same tenants I absolutely agree all
of these evidence-based strategies are
required in a good reading
program should all districts do it yes
but I don't think it's our place to
determine what district te what
districts use to teach I mean you can't
take any one caned basil program that
has these components in it and expect it
to meet the needs of all the children in
first and second grade cuz it's not I
mean kids are not all fitting in one box
they run the gamut and they learn at
different
rates and I can't support something
that's telling the districts what to do
maybe their scores are really good with
Bal balance literacy I don't know I
haven't looked at that but I can tell
you that I did find a study that I would
place a lot of value in and it's from
the PE Research Center and
forbs and Annie Casey Foundation which I
hope you're all familiar with that New
Hampshire has the highest literacy rate
94.2% now I know there's a lot of kids
that are struggling in
reading and you will always have kids
that have difficulty learning reading or
math or anything you'll never have 100%
is the goal 100% readers the goal was
that everybody should have at least the
minimum reading skills of a sixth grader
so that they can read anything out in
the public sector um so again I think
this is all great I agree with it all
I've seen it worked I trained in letters
um and I've trained in these these um
different modules it works
well but sitting on this side of the
table it's not my job to tell District B
you need to implement this program you
need to have these uh professional
development activities you need to buy
this program not that this says that but
it implies
control thank you uh representative
cordelan then representative Miler and
then representative
leas thank you I I disagree in that we
set out anything in local control here B
if anything we're setting standards and
the standard is evidence-based science
of research um science of reading
research that is the standard they're
free to choose any curriculum that meets
those criteria that they want it the
bill also instructs the Department of
Education to identify appropriate
instruction materials from which the um
School District can choose whatever ever
they want any combination thereof we're
not mandating any particular curriculum
we're not mandating any kind of
professional development
um um it it there's nothing no product
mentioned in here and in in terms of um
the uh the screener the Department of
Education has already had um a group of
uh Educators and reading Specialists
together to talk about screeners um I
was on a call uh two nights ago with um
um Melissa white and um Kate the
specialist from the Department of
Education with Carol Tolman um um from
who co-authored letters talking about
what screeners um were the top screeners
and what top screeners that they might
want to avoid so they're looking at this
already and they're moving in that
direction
um they have said that they believe that
they can find funding for one
screener if we want to do it properly
with training and
support but if we're going to do the
provide training and support in the
field you know we can't go off and have
the department buy three different
screeners for them to use and especially
if we're going to base any kind of
future grants um off of uh combination
of screeners so you know that's
addressing my view on local control and
also the screener issue repr
Miler first of all I want to thank
representative cordelli for bringing
this issue before
us um I appreciate his
passion and his uh work on this
bill I don't think anybody in this Comm
committee would disagree that reading is
critical for a Student
Success and I want to respond to
representative leak's comment about the
issue of criticizing the department
those of us that have been on this
committee have a right to criticize them
we we authorized a reading
specialist years
ago was never filled it was filled by a
language arts person not a reading
person so there in lies my suspicion
about the
department this bill is a Christmas tree
Bill what I mean by that is that it is
massive it's massive in its intent to
try to radically change the way that we
teach reading in in the school and Glenn
recognizes
that my concern is is that and I've it's
interesting because I I've been
intrigued by reading some of the emails
that we've gotten from parents who have
had children who have struggled I myself
was a struggling
reader uh and I I'll never forget uh one
of my favorite teachers Mr Levine in
fourth grade knew that I love to play
basketball and he put on the
desk backboard
magic and that was the book that got me
into being a
reader there are various ways in which I
think represent K Kon has said is that
people learn to read
and I think it it's the magic of the
teacher that tries to identify what
those what which arrows in this quiver I
need to use to make sure that that
student can in fact accomplish a reading
competency my concern about this uh
representive cordelli is that it seems
to have a single focus on an
approach that's my concern it's not it's
not the issue of the need don't I don't
deny that but I'm concerned about that
teacher out there that now has been
trained in a particular way and has been
successful in teaching get this bill now
say oh I got to change everything I
don't think that's the way we should do
things and I we've heard competing we
heard competing interest here about
approaches to reading I mean I remember
getting this long Mis from a UNH teacher
uh professor who basically said you need
multiple approaches this is okay as one
of the arrows but not the
arrow and so my my concern is that I
know I know representative cardelli
you're impatient and I I I I respect the
impatien around this but if we're going
to move in this thing it would seem to
me that we need to have a more
comprehensive look at this if we're
going to go down a particular Road and
more comprehensive look where we where
we do have the computers come in here
and talk about this one works here this
one doesn't work here here's why to have
a much more a much broader look at how
we want to go forward with
this I again I respect your work on this
good but but I think we need more I I
need more I'm not a specialist on this I
got to re rely on somebody like Ken
who's been out in the field who's who's
done this stuff
or or other teachers that are around her
that done this stuff I'm not I don't
know this and so I'm uncomfortable with
a single approach and I and I would I
would strongly recommend not just a
nonsense interim study look at this but
to be able to look at this issue as a
ground as as a foundational look to
begin a
broader review of what our options are
and what we can do and I do have a
concern about us
dictating from a legislative standpoint
we've had a long history here of not
trying to dictate curriculum from this
committee to a local school district so
that's another concern that I have but I
would hope that we would take the work
that's been started here and try to
perfect it in a much higher level than
just this this is the first time we've
looked at something like this other than
dyslexic thing and we've had success on
the dyslexic bill that we put forward
and so that that's my concern I guess of
of uh OTP this the way it is and would
really look to more of a longer term
interim study look at this I know it's
putting back I know it doesn't deal with
the impatience of it but um I I just I
I'm just uncomfortable with the
massiveness of this right now thank you
again thank you again Glenn for your
next rep cordelli basically said what I
discussion represent Hall thank you Mr
chair I have a question has a doe done
much for the different districts to
promote the science of reading do we
know what they have
done um they are uh they have a a a
specialist uh Kate mcaffrey who's going
around from District to District um
they have made the letters of program
available for free using Federal funding
um to teachers um unfortunately that
funding runs out the end of this year um
My Hope was that you know early if we
had been able to do something um last
year that we could put something in the
budget in that regard
um
um but yeah um the idea is that and with
the micro credentials that I just
mentioned that they are just starting up
to um offer um uh these micro
credentials um to teachers going through
um uh the process of learning um this
evidence-based research and teaching in
that method
followup so has it been a favorable
arisma does it sound like the districts
are saying oh yeah this is great or what
is the response other than I understand
the microc credentialing but
overall um all I can point to is um the
number of people who were in the
professional development uh session that
I attended in Londoner the room was full
I don't think there was a vacant
seat
um I was the only interloper um if you
will
um
um we have uh gotten today a petition
that's um filled with teachers
um on that I've worked with um many
teachers and um I point out that the um
the chair the tri chairs of decoding
dyslexia wrote to us um last night
indicating their support for this bill
the um uh chair of the New England
chapter of international dyslexia
Association has been working with me for
weeks on on this bill um so that's my um
firsthand view of of things you further
discussion I think we're represent beler
thank you Mr chair and I'll be brief um
i' I've outlined some of the concerns
I've had before I don't need to rehash
all of that right now my concerns do
stand um but I also wanted to speak to
on page for the lower part I I have some
first of all I'm totally on board with
the concept of
telling schools that we need to be
following where good science and good
evidence is leading us but I'm I'm also
deeply uncomfortable with the idea that
we would enshrine in law the current
findings of what we believe science to
be because the very nature of science is
it's falsifiable and things can change
in time and I I think we need to take a
different approach to that thank you
further further questions discussion not
see
any we have a motion on the
table to adopt
Amendment 2452 H and that's HP 437
pardon me second
that
yeah okay Madam clerk would you please
call the
RO Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leus yep representative
Ford yes representative Belcher no
representative dry yes representative
mcdonal yes representative Noble yes
representative Pell yes representative
corello yes representative Miler no
representative Cornell no representative
Tanner no representative Luna
no representative Heath representative
Woodcock no representative Hall no
representative bon no Representative
cascaden no representative Damon no
chairman lad
yes there's still 'sp on the floor oh
I'm sorry yeah
yeah you're to go home or
something okay we have a motion on the
floor OTP on 437 yes we all are anxious
to go home or to work or to work yeah oh
wow Madam clerk would you please call a
ro what's
this Vice chairman cordelli
yes representative leus yes
representative Ford yes Representative
belshire no representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
Pell yes representative Cory yellow yes
representative Miler no representative
Cornell no representative Tanner
Representative luno no representative
Heath no representative W no
representative Hall no representative
bon no Representative cascaden no
representative Damon no chairman laad
yes n y 11 n okay the motion OTP fails
motion to I inter study motion is now
interim study from representative Miler
Tanner further
discussion not seeing
any you're with
us Vice chairman cordelli
representative
elire
yes representative dry
no representative McDonald no
representative Noble no representative
Pell
no Representative corello no
representative
Miler representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
Luna yes
representative Heath sorry I had to put
your name down okay representative
Woodcock representative Hall yes
representative albone yes representative
cascaden yes representative Damon
yes rep uh chairman lad
NS okay you on
study we have have
left who made that motion pardon me
uh okay
uh we have uh 439
651 and
627 can we make an agreement to have one
person speak
on behalf of each one of these one way
or the other so we can get out of here
I'm running out of sheets to record our
vote so please okay so good so let's
439 439 is a bill relative to the duty
to provide an add education and
all
right repr Celli that was your bill you
have a motion to make on that one um let
me find
there yes um I would like to move uh
pass okay we have motion made by
representa cordelli OTP and second by
representative McDonald representative
recognized thank you Mr chairman um this
bill does uh one simple thing it
repeals um as you'll see on line8 of the
original Bill
uh a Roman
4 um and
that relates to um a school board
Contracting with any approved non
school that is a leftover portion of
rsas that is contrary to work we've done
in the best interest manifest education
1933 Romans
6 which
says this is basically Town
tuition if there's no public school for
child's grade in the Resident District
the school board May contract with
another Public School in another school
district or with any private school that
has been approved for school tuition
program by the school
board and it goes on from there so we've
already changed the law to reflect that
for Town tuition purposes the school
board can contract with any uh public or
private
school um what the bill attempts to do
is repeal the statute that has the um
old language um preventing Contracting
with non- sectarian uh private schools
um which we know has now been um on
multiple occasions um ruled
unconstitutional by the US Supreme Court
bill further discussion representa uh
cascaden I have an amendment to that
what is your
Amendment um the intent of this bill I
thought origin Ally was to just align
the um length of time that districts
needed to provide uh had a duty to you
are you going to introduce the amendment
oh sorry my first
Rio okay so the amendment is
um number 242
24h sorry okay is s a
second was that you represent Damon okay
go ahead okay sorry all right so the
first uh time we were introduced to this
bill it was pointed out that we were
just amending to accommodate the uh
changes in the special ed law that was
through the age 21 so the amendment in
the original
um Bill had the word inclusive and we've
kind of done that and the other bills a
deal with special ed because instead of
going up to the 21st birthday it's now
really up to the 22nd birthday so that's
what this corrects but my Amendment does
want to correct that to age
22 uh but it does not repeal 1891 I feel
that manifest educational hardship is
again one of those issues that's local
control where a local school board can
determine where a student goes it can be
non sectarian private it can be monor it
can be any place that that school board
decides to send that child no matter
where um as long as they're accepted in
the receiving School District or school
so I don't see any need um to repeal a
manifest educational hardship which
again is a local school board decision
but that we do need to make the
amendment to make sure that we have a
duty to provide um up to age 22 until
the student turns 22 so that's my
Amendment further
discussion
yes represent cordelli yes um
representative you are correcting that
this does revise that one section of St
statute is been there also was missed in
relation to age uh 21 inclusive um in
addition to the repeal um but um it's
really the um section of law for Town
tuition under manifest education chart
hardship that has been revised um a
couple of years ago so that it can uh
they can tuition to any private school
um if if any
um School
Board refuses to contract with a non
sectarian private school based on
Supreme Court decisions they'll be
immediately in court the Supreme Court
in Espinosa versus Montana um uh caen
versus Mak over in Maine just um uh a
year year ago both revie uh said said
that The Establishment Clause says you
cannot
exclude a non
sectarian School a religious school if
you do any Contracting with any private
school
um so um
you're by leaving this in
statute um it's I think what did I call
it um a dead letter
issue it's a dead letter section of the
law as the um New Hampshire Supreme
Court um has uh ained in that it's
statute that cannot be enforced because
of the US Supreme Court
decisions um they called it a dead
letter um
provision and that's what we would be um
leaving in
statute further
discussion yes represent luno yeah
thanks so a question on on that so are
you saying that public school boards
have to contract with with religious
schools they have no choice but to
contract religious yes no they have
Choice yeah but me yeah they can
contract with but to say you cannot
contract with a religious school that's
unconstitutional because what you said
was right if a school board did not
contract with relig with a religious
school they would be hul in the court
right away they can contract with they
don't have to contract with correct
relig yes if I if I said that I misspoke
okay okay and and and then my other uh
question question is because I I think
on the top part
of the
bill as introduced which the the
cascaden amendment does not touch leaves
in place the 21 inclusive um currently
it just says age 21 doesn't have the
word inclusive in there so under federal
law the fact that New Hampshire law is
inconsistent doesn't really matter um is
that right I mean that sort of cleanup
language the inclusive we've changed
that we changed it elsewhere right right
I know I know we have I've been involved
in that right so this is right to bring
this uh section of the statutes in uh
alignment with other sections that we
already cleaned federal law and federal
law and federal law yes well federal law
says um you don't have to do it to make
it 22 but it's a a state option to make
it 22 and Most states are moving in that
direction I think most all New England
has done that okay
thanks further
discussion not seeing any so we have a a
recommendation for uh 242
24h to
439 so that's what we'll be voting on
right now the cascaden
amendment any further
discussion Madam clerk on the cas
Amendment
yes Vice chairman
cordelli no Representative leus no
representative Ford no representative
Belcher no representative dry no
representative McDonald no
representative Noble no representative
Pell no represent corello no
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative luno yes representative
Heath yes representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes representative
Balon yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad no
10 y
10 okay no recommendation
there um now we're back to the original
motion ought to pass on 439 as presented
to
forward on that you see I'm no this is
the bill has introduced now right y
okay
good that's
right further discussion on the bill as
introduced
not seeing
anybody uh wanting to discuss a further
represent cordel
here chair Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leus yeah representative
Ford yes representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative Pell yes representative
corello yes representative
no representative Cornell no
representative Tanner no Representative
luno no representative Heath no
Representative wock no representative
Hall no representative bon no
Representative cascaden no
representative Damon no chairman lad yes
10 go
ahead we got a motion itl from
representative Miler second anywhere
represent
Tanner represent my you want to discuss
Tanner Madam
y Vice chairman
cordelli no
Representative leus no representative
Ford no representative Belcher no
representative dry no representative
McDonald no representative Noble no
representative Pell no representative
Coro no representative Miler yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
luno yes representative Heath yes
representative wock yes representative
Hall yes representative Bon yes
representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad
l y next one down HB 553 information on
personal
beach beach okay oops I'm sorry it's
[Applause]
each I can do the a to pass motion to
start with right while you're passing
fingers
okay uh everybody should have copies
right now represent Cordell you re
recognize for a motion uh thank you Mr
chairman I'd like to move ought to pass
553 is there a second on
553 I'll
second represent Pell seconds the
motion represent cordelli you're
recognized yes I'd like to offer
second second represent penell seconds
2417h go ahead represent thank you um
basically this uh
Amendment um tightens up the language of
the original Bill and that um School
Board shall publish uh a complete list
of each position title along with the
annual or hourly
salary in addition um there is a report
that also is coming around that each
district currently also fills out for
the Department of Education and I
thought would it would be instructable
to have that information posted along
with the salary information for each
position on their website
um the idea is
twofold um I I think it's I think will
bear be very interesting um to see what
the salaries are to see um what
administrator positions there are we've
heard about the growth of administrative
positions as opposed to teacher
positions and the pay um going to
administrators versus uh teachers um I
think that be instructive for uh
everybody us included um and the public
in each district um but also I I think
it might be instructive for the
teachers to see their salaries compared
with the administrator salaries um you
know we've heard about teacher
Recruitment and everything else um you
know maybe show having the teachers
really see what they're getting paid as
opposed to others are getting paid um
you know might um lend some uh Credence
to um their contract discussions next
time around so I I I'm putting this
forward with basically a two-fold
purpose um thank
discussion yes represent pel yes our
school district um actually does List
names along with the annual salary
however it's not listed by position it's
listed alphabetically and I actually
think that that's unfair because now I
know what how much money my neighbor is
making whether or not I want to know
that if I wanted to look at the list um
but I think this would be really helpful
um in terms of understanding how much is
spent on Administration versus actual
student
instruction representative
moo thank you very much Mr chair so um
you know I I appreciate that um that the
um that the prime sponsor wants us to be
able to have access to that in this
information that we may find it useful
but in fact we do have access to that
information you're just going over to
the um Department of
Education uh website um look up the
administrator Sol reports I can read
through kentu Valley SAU office
superintendent
$171,600 a year Kent Valley Au office
assistant superintendent 14196 and you
can go right down and it's got every
District right on it and and literally
it if I was curious if I wanted to find
that information you're seconds away
from it um right now and uh so not only
is the information available through the
um uh through the uh Department of Ed
but um but my understanding at least my
understanding of our school district um
where I'm you know served his chair for
8 years and was on it 12 years um uh we
make that information available uh to uh
anybody that uh that comes in and and
asks for it so and of course you know in
a small school district a lot of
teachers the position identifies the
teacher um so it's a little bit of a of
a you know you know practice that
exposes uh uh identifies I should say uh
specific people but that's part of
transparency and that's part of uh
working as a public
leus the administrator superintendence
whatever that are on there doesn't
include all of the things that are on
this form because one of one of one of
my constituents specifically asked if
they could how they would find out all
the different positions and what they
were paid and um I didn't know that the
letters a2d were what I needed and a lot
of constituents don't so they should be
able to see it without having to know
a2d um but no it was totally
insufficient for what we were trying to
find yes we got the
superintendant ETC but we did not get
all of the rest of the people like the
pr person and the Dei person and all
those other people we couldn't find them
and we had no idea how much they were be
being paid or anything and that is part
of the the structure and the money
that's being spent so I think this is
great because now we get to see all of
them not just those few thank you I I
have a a concern and and and this is the
one bill I do have a concern on a lot of
bills but I brought in I believe when it
was introduced and showed people the
annual report from town of
havil it lists every
employee with their positions and the
amount of money that they're receiving
for that position
annually and we've been doing that ever
since I've lived in that Community I I
think this is this can be done because
their Town's doing it uh I can't say
it's being done throughout this entire
state but I know that in my particular
town this information is published
annually and used at the school meeting
or at the town meeting oftentimes used
all these teachers are overpaid you know
$8,000,000 a year uh it's it's uh it's
needed represent
cell U when transparency was mentioned
and I am all for
transparency um
um I feel like the more places this
information could be provided the better
if it's easier to find all the better so
I I support this some people may not
know to go to the Department of
Education um maybe the I know um some
towns have different ways of putting
their annual reports online some towns
don't put them on there at all um but
I'm I'm all for the the more places you
can put this information the better
because I think it is good to see the
difference in uh administrative salaries
how much is going towards that um and
how many positions there might be maybe
there are too many and maybe that'll
show that um and how that compares to
what teachers are making um
so further represent dry and then
represent hner thank you Mr chairman I
appreciate the um example from your town
in our town exactly the same thing
happens every cemetery worker
instruction worker sound
administrator uh assistant Librarian Is
on uh with the salary and a name um none
of the teachers are it's a graph you
have to look at what the teacher studied
where they went to school what degree
they have find out where it is do the
math to compute how long they've been
and try to find out where they fall on a
a grid scale um it's completely obtuse
and nobody uses it uh I don't know why
we have one set of uh employees that are
are transparent to the letter and and
all further to refence N Tanner um
several times during my teaching career
uh when some people thought it was going
to be dis disruptive to everybody
because I think that's why um it was
done all our names and and salaries were
published in the local paper and the
surprising thing was that a lot of
people had the the same thing as as
representative petronel they were
surprised what their neighbors made or
didn't make um but for what good does
this do and that's that's does it help
Public Schools does it help uh anything
is it an added regulation um certainly
91a they could find out um there's also
they just have to go to the SAU office
and the SAU office will give them the
salaries and and the names of the people
that have we're public employees our
information is public information um to
put it out in the in the in the paper
like it was was as I said more
disruptive than it than it did any good
and and so what's the good of doing this
what what is the ultimate intent or goal
of publishing all these names and
leus I think part of the intent is is
Teachers aren't paid
enough and people don't realize how much
they're not paid and the teachers don't
realize where the money is going and so
we have
administrators we have Dei Specialists
and PR people who are making more money
than the teachers and I think the idea
is to get it out there and make it
public where all of that money is going
and yes maybe the teachers need a raise
and maybe yes we need to get rid of some
of those other positions so they can get
a
raise further
discussion yes representative MCD thank
you Mr chair I was thinking in the
interest of maybe a larger School
District where there are multiple
positions I mean multiple people filling
same position for example kindergarten
teacher and you have more than one or
for any position and there might be
different salaries among them in this
bill would they be listed as you know
kindergarten teacher one kindergarten
teacher too or how exactly would that
work that would be up to them but I
would uh Envision something like that
clerk Vice chairman cordelli this is on
the amendment
correct yes
right adopting the amendment
yeah right so Vice chairman cordelli
yes representative leus yes
representative Ford yes representative
Belcher yes representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
pill yes representative corello yes
representative Miler no representative
Cornell no representative Tanner NOP
representative Luna no representative
Heath representative W no representative
Hall no representative
bone no Representative cascaden no
representative Damon no chairman lad yes
days okay we have the main Motion in
front of us right now OTP as amended
with
2417h is it ought to pass as amended or
ought to pass it's it's the it was
1010 oh oh it was 1010 it was 1010 right
yeah okay that okay be off to pass it's
amended yeah Vice chairman cordelli
yes representative leus yes
representative Ford yes representative
Belcher yes representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
Pell yes representative corello yes
representative Miler no representative
Cornell representa Tanner no represent
Representative luno no representative
Heath Representative wout no
representative Hall no representative
bon no representative cascaden and o no
representative d
yes yes what's your motion itl got a
motion for itl there a
second represent Cornell so Miler
Cornell
itl further discussion Madam
clerk Vice chairman
cordelli no
Representative leus no representative
Ford no Representative beler no
McDonald can you repeat the question it
this itl no sorry okay uh representative
Noel no representative Pell no
Representative corello no representative
Miler
C yes
represent represent
Cornell representative Tanner yes
representative luno yes representative
Heath representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes representative
albone yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad no
days did you learn how to say C down in
Hilton
Head
okay
networks we were talking about that
earlier today right I believe an
side okay
any have any ex copies one I'm looking
you
transort
so we was there a motion already on the
floor in this one no no so we hadn't
gone there yet
okay okay we have HB
651 uh a bill dealing authorizing
transportation of pupils by contractor
vehicles I recognize represent cordelli
for a motion
thank you I'm having a fun afternoon um
I would like to move on to
pass is there a
second
second second by representative Ford
represent cordelli yes I would like to
offer Amendment 2425 H is Sir a
2425 represent Ford no no she that he
had her hand I thought he was point yeah
motion earlier when we received this I
just want to know where we are you was
sent out for a questioning on Germaine
that's correct has there been a reing on
that yes there has been the ring is that
Germaine that was made by the speaker's
office yes yes by the chief of
rep chief of smoke and the artillery
battery as the you
know okay um I I believe we discussed
this um a little bit um earlier but uh
this is the result of work with um the
department of motor
vehicles
um they um advis that the um School
transportation vehicle be included in
these statutes and also with the
Department of Education who um uh
recommended the uh addition on the uh
last page page three of relation to
background checks um this is Niche
Transportation uh it's not meant to
replace yellow buses or anything like
that it's niche Transportation foster
care special needs homeless children in
particular um um
Transportation ISS issues that come up
during the course of the year after bus
routes have already been set um I was at
a uh DCF foster care conference um I
think three Saturdays ago and
participated in a panel um and uh the uh
people in the foster care uh Community
were very interested in this um some of
the stories are amazing in terms of long
long term placements with a foster care
family and within 12 hours notice the
child is taken away from them and put in
a different placement and that new
school district then has to provide um
arrange for transportation to get that
child to school so I think that this
helps in a number of areas um we spent
hours working with uh uh the
commissioner who was here earlier with
uh two other Troopers who were involved
in that meeting and the school bus um
Trooper um uh in charge basically who
cannot be here today because he's uh
undergoing surgery um but um that's uh
why I'm bringing forward this bill and
the
background further
discussion yes represent cascaden I just
have a question on how different is this
from the statute on multi-use
vehicles um it was felt that it was
sufficiently dis uh difference and
you'll see the definition on line seven
and eight um there would be P your
button um I'm sorry thank you um uh
there will be several companies who are
interested in providing this service in
New Hampshire that will hire um drivers
and then um contract with districts um
for these um uh Niche type of uh
situations um that
uh come up and they will be in um
vehicles um smaller Vehicles eight
passenger
um and as I said this this one company
in particular that we've been working
with most recently is in 28 States doing
this further discussion yes representa
Tanner so are um you know I the the two
big things for school transportation or
student transportation is the inspection
of the buses and the certificate of the
drivers um and I think school bus
drivers have to have a CDL license um in
New Hampshire and also
um it doesn't say that these uh buses or
uh Vans I guess they are buses owned by
religious organizations or a
nonprofit uh used exclusively as a bus
for
transportation um is it is
the ones that I see where now schools
contract
with somebody that uh has their own
personal car but has the insurance
carrier and everything else that they
need to qualify have a little sign on
them school bus or School vehicle or
whatever um and I don't see anything in
in this that would designate those those
particular Vans as providers of school
transportation um I don't see the CDL
license I don't see
um all all that was reviewed with uh U
the department of safety DMV um and the
gentlemen who were here earlier all that
was reviewed and we went through in
detail through all the administrative um
rules as well um and made sure that for
instance this one company who's most
interested right now um would have no
problem following all all of these um
statutory references as well as all the
okay which and I think CDL license is
only required for certain size Vehicles
well there's this I know that there used
to be a special license for van drivers
that were driving school school you know
um School operated because I drove some
for the for coaching but we had to get a
special license for that right um and um
it wasn't a CDL but it was a special
special license and and a
physical exam um you know there's
there's a lot of it that's defined to
make sure that it's safe and we went
detailed through every administrative
rule um applying to school
transportation um with this Trooper who
um basically runs the program monitors
the program and um went through it line
by line so that we knew um is there a
waiver available from this because of um
the situation um and um will the company
comply with uh you know X Rule and so
every every rule was covered um and
reviewed um and uh um the uh company
involved right now was um uh agreeable
to U every one of the applicable rules
as well as these provisions of
laws but they were against it at
first weren't they when we first had was
in a different section of law and the
department of safety was not crazy about
the section of law that's why this
amendment has moved it to a different
section of law um under the traditional
more under Traditional School
transportation whereas the other was um
the original bill was in a section for
Network Transportation which is uh
different thank
you further discussion represent B Bon
um I guess thank you Mr chair um I think
that there's a lot that's in here that's
being presented at the last minute and I
don't see any supporting documentation
or anybody here to ask um because I know
when we looked at the first one uh this
the state police I believe were against
it so I I find it just difficult to be
asked to vote on something that I I just
saw you know um an hour ago so
unfortunately we thought we would be
getting to this earlier and the uh the
director of DMV was here along with two
of the Troopers who were involved in the
meetings um but they had to had to leave
time further discussion represent luno
so thank you very much Mr chair and and
you know my apologies to the members of
the committee I certainly challenged
whether or not the um the the amendment
was was Germaine and um I'm I'm
surprised by the response but I
certainly accept the response uh and the
reason I'm surprised by it though is
because the sections are all different
than what was proposed and the language
is all different than what was proposed
and I have the same concern that
representative balbon just um just
articulated that that that we we we
haven't really uh fact we haven't held
public hearing on the new language we
haven't had the opportunity to find out
what the experience has been in the 28
states that do use is it is it ever
right what's the name of it everen ever
driven um and and I I have I have
nothing to suggest anything about you
know ever driven as a company or what
their safety record and stuff but I
don't know and and I haven't had a
chance to um none of us have had a
chance to um to ask ask and um and and
then you know going going past ever
driven to all right what are some of the
other um situations that could uh could
be developed could uh could you know a
person say hey I'm going to use my
personal vehicle I'm going to set up a
uh a oneperson company and I'm going to
drive students from point A to point B
and uh following all of the the um
requirement that are that are listed
here potentially a lot less than what
ever driven subjects their their drivers
to we just don't know because we haven't
had a chance to hold a hearing on it and
I guess finally I'd say I think there's
enough difference here that that I would
suspect had this been maybe it has been
filed as a bill for
2024 that that why wasn't this filed as
a new piece of legislation so that we
could could actually hold a hearing on
it
discussion yes rep Mr chair that's fine
I just um has an RFP gone out for this
service um usually when the state does
something there's a series of interviews
and a variety of people who looked at
you go through a whole process has that
happened the state would not be
contracting with them this would be on a
there's no particular company or
anything named in here and it's it's the
same thing only put in the right
places and it's just or provider of
school transportation vehicle services
and I went over and talked to the
gentleman who came in to find out why
they were here because I thought maybe
they were here for um
background checks and they said no they
were here in case we had any questions
for this they said as far as they were
concerned it was very straightforward
it's exactly the same thing whether it's
a school bus or some other provider they
have to jump through all the same oops
they have to do the same thing and so
they they didn't they thought it would
just go through they didn't see a
problem with it um because we're just
requiring all the same things just
or School
transportation or you know or provider
of school transportation vehicle
services but so I don't understand what
the big deal is
but further discuss represent Celli yeah
I just wanted to point out one other
um several companies I I've talked to um
they both and in this case I'm just
looking at it now ever driven they
provide the parent with an app so they
can track in real time where their
student is which is um pretty nice uh
feature um get real time
information
um so
um it's unfortunate that they had to
leave um I'm sorry and the uh um the
trooper involved in school
transportation had hoped to be here but
um unfortunately he he can't because of
surgery further
discussion not seeing
any we have amendment in front of us
here
2425 dealing with transportation of
pupils by contracted School
transportation
Vehicles not have any further the the
recommendations OTP for the
amendment representa cordello
Vice chairman
cordelli yes representative leus yes
representative Ford yes representative
beler yes representative dry yes
representative McDonald no
representative Noble yes representative
Pell yes representative corello yes
representative Miler
yes representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes your plans
represent luno
no representative Heath
no Representative wock no representative
Hall
no representative Boni no representative
cascaden uh no representative Damon
no chairman lad
names
okay now we have the the bill that's in
front of us here I don't know to you
OTP with the
discussion not seeing
clerk Vice chairman
cordelli yes yes representative leus
yeah representative Ford yes
representative beler yes representative
dry yes representative McDonald no
representative Noble yes representative
Pell yes representative Coro yes
representative Miler no representative
Cornell
no representative Tanner no
Representative luno no representative
Ellison I'm sorry okay long day all
right sorry did well
representative wock representative Hall
no Representative abon no Representative
cascaden no representative Damon no
chairman lad
yes nine y 11
fails another another
motion a motion itl made by represent
Miler second by represent luno wood
Woodcock no he second that I didn't I
voice so who down there did it luno luno
okay was the only
yeah woodcock's gonna write it though
he's gonna write
so Madam Clerk Vice chairman
cordelli no Representative leus no
representative Ford no representative
Belcher no representative try no
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble
no representative
Pell no representative cor yellow no
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative luno yes representative
Heath yes representative W yes
representative Hall yes representative
albon yes representative cascaden yes
represent Damon yes chairman
lad
uh I'm tired we all are um what's our
position that no yeah I forget what
we're you voting
at I'm thinking other things
I supposed to pick the kids up from
school
tonight not going to do that was the
toal miss
check you right thank you David okay
folks we have one more
627 is relative to location local
education Improvement plans and
education this isn't one no this is not
yours we had this bill in a
subcommittee so giving a subcommittee
report it was not
um I don't believe that bill was
supported in
subcommittee trying to look at it and
recall it was an itl was supp
it committee yeah it deals with
RSA 193 H and we had H and E and K and
everything else going on with the other
bill at the time and we felt that this
this bill you know we're dealing with it
in two 66 uh
so so can I make a motion to yes you may
itl really no and and I'll second
it so leus made the motion I second it
627 any further
discussion let's vote on
it
Vice chairman cordelli
yes representative leus yes
representative Ford yes representative
beler yes representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
Pell yes representative corello yes
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative Luna
yes representative Heath representative
W yes representative Paul yes
representative alone yes representative
cascaden yes represent Damon yes
chairman lad yes 20 A's zero
a did we learn something from this today
moment consent
before before we go I'll make copies
before we go I think we all need to
thank represent cordello for the work I
this is a this is a difficult job and
job buy dinner too yeah yeah she is late
for work got UFO resar coming for a
program oh really um I are you going I
cop can she make copies right now yeah
um so represent representative luno and
representative Cornell we never resolved
the other bill and if we're going to
make any kind of recommendation we're
recommendation